all right
this is basically shout out to the
family
this is what he does after he says it
[Music]
this one is dedicated
to george floyd's family
[Music]
shout out to family
[Music]
shout out shout out to his family
shout out to all the veterans of world
war ii
[Music]
shout out to that 750 000 who died of
covet
that's it
that's it
welcome everybody it's h32p it's monday
thanksgiving week
[Applause]
and you know we never take the day off
i'll tell you what you go to traditional
media
those guys taking like not just the week
off
the attack like the written to the year
off unbelievable i'm serious
you look at late night
you look at bill maher
howard stern i'm just i'm just throwing
names out all these big names they peace
out
guess who's here
all of us we're all here whether we want
to be or not here we are
exactly that's what work is
you you now shut up you you uh wage
slave that's right they work themselves
to death
doing impossible things oh boy are you
uh upset that everybody's saying
hassan's jordan peterson's uh i don't
know why they gotta make such a big deal
about it it's pretty good i know it's
good but why you gotta why you gotta
make it about like that it's better than
mine that's right just say it's better
it's a good one just say it's a good one
it's a very good one it's really like
how would we be without hassan doing
jordan peterson
[Laughter]
well it's too early zach yeah come on
yeah i'm pissed about it obviously
well at least i have a good hairline he
doesn't so [ __ ] him
he doesn't have a good hairline it's
pretty good but it's thinning i mean
he's thinning
his hairline is actually good but his
hair is thinning is my point
okay so no matter what
i'll always have that on him
is what i'm trying to say
here we'll let you have that one
okay
h3tv uh sponsored by jen lock
honey and raycon we love our sponsors
thank you guys
today or this week we are only not doing
leftovers because we record on thursday
thursday's thanksgiving other than that
it's a full week baby friday we're going
to be here it's all happening
on the industry podcast
got a lot of fun stuff here what are you
what are you guys all doing for
thanksgiving now well i was about to say
uh a decent chunk of the crew actually
won't be here on friday because they're
uh going out of town for the holiday but
i'll be here
who who's gonna who's gonna be here on
friday i'll be here
ian will be here right yeah yeah and
olivia okay shout outs and love of
course and love because they don't
respect doesn't observe
the holy holiday that's right do you
know what manifest destiny is
do you even know bro do you even know
no i've never eaten yeah well be careful
i'm going to manifest sweden i'm going
to fast destiny of sweden into part of
america that's right
they
they said just the western hemisphere
that's not enough you want to know what
it is it's pretty it's pretty messed up
it was this idea when we colonized we i
i wasn't here
neither were my answers
i don't i don't want to see that blood
on my hands
when the uh when the pilgrims came here
and they colonized the east coast
eventually
you know they came up with this theory
called manifest destiny which said that
god it was god's plan for america to
take
all of america from the east to the west
coast
and it was god's plan uh
and here we are the whole that's what
the drake song is actually about
it's the blood of god that's right
that's so inspiring which one it's
called manifest destiny which drake's no
god's plan oh god's plan
yeah so that but they used that to
basically you know
justify killing a bunch of indians or
native americans and stuff like that
and mexicans too actually
it's [ __ ] up
yeah well who are you you're how dare
you vikings how dare you
how dare you love
good take love i agree okay yeah well
why didn't you do anything about it then
no okay okay dude
i'm just kidding
nah sweet sweets are great
swedes are so they're the good people
they're the good people of the earth
all right so um
lots of good stuff
today i want to just give a shout out to
eli kleiner's
seven days left on the black friday sale
it's a little confusing now because it's
looney tunes so sort of saying i wonder
i don't know if we need to like change
it back to black friday
but if you want to see what's on sale
just click sale at the top
black friday
only seven days left
get there wow it's hot
we've got a lot to talk ryan cavanaugh's
on the menu today i'm happy to say
rank there's been some stride there's
actually been a lot of strife with ryan
kavanagh and actually we had um
one of the hearings
oh yeah we had a hearing update
how'd it go for the um
the deaf well it's not defamation but
it's that one for one that lawsuit it
went very well
actually i got a transcript let me ask
rom if we can read from it
um because it was our lawyers doing oral
arguments to the judge well you don't
think we should read from it
oh well whatever
he's my lawyer
let me ask him
can we read
the transcript
on the show
a lot of the chat is curious how your
beanie is staying i was about to comment
on your being
i'm the pope
yeah
it's very wrecked
beanie
it's just i don't know i have a i have a
power maybe it's because my hair is so
thick
but i got
i have no problem standing kind of smurf
energy i have no problem standing a
beanie fully erect on my head i'll tell
you that i may not be able to keep it up
but i can keep this up
you do not have bd beanie dysfunction no
i'm sir that beanie's not erect that's
like full that's like fire and bruh it's
more pleasing
[ __ ] on me get that [ __ ] weirdo off
my screen
freak
can you bring that back actually
why they gotta make them like that this
i guess is from like the new movie or
this is from like
why his eyes so detailed there's no need
for that
he's very frightening i don't like him
it's not good
i never really was a fan of the smurfs i
gotta say as cartoons when they would
come on on cartoon network when i was a
kid i would i'd always i agree i think
it's made up at best and best i don't
know why everybody got to do like movies
and [ __ ] nobody care about the smurfs
i do no no smurfs slander here please
really are you an anime are you an
anti-semite
no
really
because gargamel
is clearly an anti-semitic
yeah well he's the bad guy no no he yeah
exactly he's the bad guy you know
exactly no no you you are wrong dan you
said he's an anti-semite the villain you
mean he looks like a jewish caricature
yeah i was saying love is an anti-semite
because he's defending them
yes yes yes yes
yeah sorry about that yeah do you think
that i hate the jews
okay guys thank you
enough
we've got two yellow episodes in a row
i'm not trying to temp fate
true
no don't say jew around here
you know we've been testing with titles
and stuff
and uh
apparently the word feet in the title
yellows the video instant demonetization
like something's going on lately with um
oh i can't read the transcript damn
damn but it went it went well i can say
that okay
okay
so anyway i have all kinds of harvey uh
harvey weinstein updates
oh [ __ ] i mean
ryan cavanaugh right yeah
i confused the two for example you you
guys know that on our website does
um which you want to you want to google
it
does or just well google ryan kavanagh
right love just google ryan kavanagh
right right right and then go down to
the website
i think ryan kavanagh has been like
targeting us or something because we're
dropping dude
yeah because he's because well allegedly
based on evidence we've seen he's pa oh
no it's right here it's on the second
page
yeah you gotta get that first page he's
but i'm saying he like a leg based on
things that people have told us he's
paying people on click farms to just
spend all time like there's why do you
think of all the [ __ ] ryan kavanagh that
the first thing article that comes up is
how triller became ryan kavanaugh's
biggest comeback and not
and not [ __ ] that's way more [ __ ]
relevant like who's actually reading
that article the [ __ ] that people are
reading is does ryan cavanaugh look like
harvey weinstein and ryan kavanagh
accused my ex partner of running ponzi
scheme a huge article by variety
bombshell
you know uh and then here's some videos
by this guy ryan cavanaugh's a big fat
idiot
right kavanaugh's gone insane
those should be at the top of some name
yeah i love that thumbnail but anyway if
you go to this website
which i encourage everyone to do
and then
if you how do they get to the game to go
to the bottom
yeah
all right we actually does not look very
good a celebrity playing the game yeah
yeah so the reason i'm showing you this
is just because actually snoop dogg
was playing the game on his stream you
guys this is crazy yeah
he's really struggling too
it's hard
it just shows you
[ __ ]
see he got it wrong it's stressful
because it's so hard
see i don't know which one that is yet
i don't know
he's rocking wendy williams fart remix
too
[Music]
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i know damn it it's hard
it is everything went [ __ ] bad yeah
[ __ ] this so it's a stressful game it's
a difficult game snoop did his best
and uh he sucks to see him get that that
upset
yeah
but i'm glad to see him playing our game
yeah you guys should go up there and try
it out it's it's very challenging
so the one thing i want to say about
ryan
there's so much to get to but this rank
having a stuff is so good you guys gonna
like it
okay so kavkav
who okay let's just say allegedly this
is kavkev
i mean there's some pretty compelling
evidence
but he's been okay this account i'm just
gonna say up front this account which we
believe is ryan kavanaugh has been
arguing with the moderators of his
wikipedia page
i don't think he understands that this
is public he was threatening to sue them
he was harassing them
and they banned his they had to ban his
account
for being so belligerent
now you guys got to check this out and
what he's what this person who's we
suspect to be ryan cavanaugh
is uh and why well let me just tell you
why up front so that the user's name
who's arguing
i'm trying to find it is
um
it's like rk yeah
okay do you guys know do you guys have
any guess what rk could uh stand for by
the way this is the same [ __ ] guy who
edited
who made forged documents accusing his
president of uh
sexual harassment sh
under the name kavkav
so this guy is not a genius uh
he's not a genius uh hacker
in fact he likes to do dumb [ __ ] under
his name
you don't even have to be logged into
wikipedia to make changes you do have to
argue with mods and threaten them
without
but it's just like such an unforced
error like why well yeah why would you
forge a document under the user kavkav
like who could that be
that's why we call him cav cav
yeah so um rk ryan kavanagh also he
slips up a little bit here i'm just
putting this for posterity because if he
tries to sue me
i'll say that i i'm alleging based on
evidence here
he also slips out suggesting it could be
r kelly oh r kelly could be editing ryan
kavanaugh's page that's true i got it
that definitely makes sense to me what
he'd be spending his time on oh oh but
wait the 28th of august
uh 2021 yeah r kelly um is in prison
at that time he might have internet
access
i think it's important to leave options
open that it could be other people like
r kelly right who has a vested interest
in ryan kavanagh's reputation
because because um
you know they were both falsely accused
of uh r word
oh [ __ ] no sorry sorry sorry that was
harvey weinstein
oh
i take that back 100
ryan was never accused of sh or essay or
anything like that right he just falsely
accuses others
yes he right he's the one
other people he's accusing me but he
himself has never been accused of such
and so i take that back completely i was
thinking of harvey weinstein right
well maybe
well actually you know it could be
interesting
you know what could be interesting is r
kelly thinks
ryan's harvey weinstein and so he has a
vested interest
in protecting his reputation because he
feels like they're kindred oh
yes yes
they walk the same path
this one worse than one this isn't the
i'm trying to find the red opposed
because it had okay yeah
yeah so someone on our subreddit some
genius noticed this infighting
and it's so funny you guys
i'm so happy and we found this
because it also highlights that ryan
kavanaugh is
either himself or paying someone to keep
his wikipedia page clean
um there's apparently a controversies
portion that he keeps erasing
so
wait sorry guys so here he is
admitting it's him so here's a little
evidence
he said um so maybe i am not up to speed
but it's blah blah blah he says it's
that part in green that's pertinent
oh [ __ ] i didn't even
this [ __ ] said it's me you are
harming yep
it sure sounds like it's him
[ __ ]
this guy is really just an idiot
how did this guy get any faith or
success or fame i'm rich parents oh is
that what it was i forget the exact
details but yeah his uh i think his dad
was like a hedge fund manager okay
that explains everything yep
because his wikipedia page is just a
puff piece written by
by himself apparently
yeah
bro i don't know what so ryan kavanagh
apparently this super high power you
know
individual who's apparently got time to
argue with people on wikipedia
i don't have time for that [ __ ] okay and
i don't run trailer or
fight club or any of that [ __ ]
all right so here we go
so ryan cavanaugh
so here's the edit section of of his
wikipedia page
so
the newly added information is part of a
paid disinformation campaign it is
refuted by newer more reputable articles
um this user who has said that
he's ryan
right
or maybe i'll just say rk rights
how should i reference this
okay
yeah
rk writes h3 podcast has paid editors to
add the new content which is not new but
part of a malicious disinformation
campaign intended on smearing
r kavanaugh
also rk
this needs a thorough review and those
editors making these changes should be
thoroughly investigated for being paid
to harm a party knowingly so that's rk
complaining okay
and then here
the editor
says
i'm confused by this so he wrote to be
clear i'm not paid anything it's me
harming or was that not the moderator
who wrote that
uh it is him
you see afterwards and yeah the
formatting on wikipedia is like insane i
don't know why it is so difficult to
follow but paid to modify pages to harm
people initiating a lawsuit this party
is part of a so this is what i already
read no
yeah it's because it's embedded it's
like a forum
to be clear i'm not being paid anything
it's me you are harming
he's just he's following up so that's
ryan kavanagh i mean it sure sounds like
it
okay well let's keep reading
um
please don't get offended the things i
mentioned okay so this is the writer
yeah please don't get offended the
things i mentioned were reported by the
most credible sources new york times and
variety i understand your coi what is
that
i don't
know it must be some wikipedia inside
baseball thing yeah
ryan has taken the time to train himself
as a wikipedia moderator
so that he could police his own page
you got anything there
conflict of interest or kcoi is the
statement of coverage issued yeah it's
probably conflict of interest it is yeah
i understand your conflict of interest
with the page and actually you are being
paid to keep the page clean so please
first learn the wikipedia rules and
policies all published sources good or
bad could be added to wikipedia right
that's what the editor said
yeah and i just looked it up on
it is explicitly part of their
terms of service or guideline or
whatever which is what
conflict advantages involves
contributing wikipedia about yourself
family friends clients employers or your
financial and other uh relationships so
why the [ __ ] so like this is this is a
huge
talk about conflict of interest
i mean here you have the guy the page is
about
arguing and threat okay let me continue
uh you have not included accurate
information you have included
information the h3 podcast has been
trying to spread for their own financial
game what the [ __ ] am i gaining from
[ __ ] on you dude
you're literally costing me hundreds of
thousands of dollars for a dumb lawsuit
that you're initiating against me what
financial gain that's slander bro
[Music]
which has been wholly refuted by
reputable press since really attitude
that what added to the page then
no matter how h3 has been sued
no matter since h3 has been sued and
that i
and that is what prompted this attack
by them
this user is being added to the suit
there you go
so the editor who added this part
is being added to the suit and will be
held responsible for causing intentional
harm painting a knowingly false light
libel and interference and contentual
relationships how is this not
ryan yeah clearly by the way
what a [ __ ] douchebag
this this editor added excerpts from
[ __ ] new york times and variety
articles and he's threatening an edit do
you see what a psychotic fruit this guy
is
and it also enters his mind he thinks
that having money and being able to sue
people shuts up everyone and i'm here to
prove him that that's just not the
[ __ ] case okay sorry to tell you ryan
cavanaugh but you met your [ __ ] match
and a dude who doesn't give a [ __ ] that
you can sue him because i'm just gonna
break it to you bro i've been through
this before i'm gonna do the right thing
and i'm gonna expose you for being a
litigious [ __ ] liar piece of [ __ ]
that you are okay
and you're not gonna get away with it
this time and i got [ __ ] i have
enough money to wear i don't give a [ __ ]
dude i'll i will waste hundreds of
thousands of dollars to fight you in
court and that's what the [ __ ] it's all
about
you had a chance to end this [ __ ] and
now we're gonna tango
and shout out to the mod who apparently
is being sued now for adding have you
ever heard of such insanity uh so he
goes um he continues so maybe i'm not up
to speed on wiki terms
as to how to use the rules to slander
malign and harm someone but i certainly
understand the law no you do not
and now you have forced me to do so it's
ryan
it's ryan
yep how petty and pathetic are you to be
arguing and the
margins of your own wikipedia page you
guys talk about conflict of interest
what is it when you have somebody that
something better to do yeah literally
than just like he should sitting on his
computer he most definitely should have
something better to do this is why
triller is going to fail
sounds like he should govern himself
accordingly oh yeah
yeah so i don't know if you guys think
that this is legit like this seems like
something that should be brought to
wikipedia's attention of
this basically he's keeping
he's keeping controversies off his page
and threatening people who add it with
lawsuits
that is not co that is not okay that's
definitely terms of service
if you have not included accurate
information you have included
information the pop wait is did i read
that yeah
this is awesome isn't it
so [ __ ] good
here he go he continues the editor has
been trying along with two others since
july to add a controversy section and to
delete anything are you do you guys able
to see what controversies thing he keeps
erasing
because that should be in the editing
notes right yeah
yeah try to add that in
i want to know what he's so desperate to
remove
you know
because i think if it's well sourced and
well written it should be in there
why should he be able to control the
flow of information
so again i'll restart uh this header has
been trying along with two others since
july to add a controversy section and
delete anything positive
but add negative this stems from a
podcast owner ethan klein of h3 as we
initiated a litigation against them for
copyright infringement he has gone on a
public smear campaign and paid editors
to try to include misleading and twisted
negative statements that's going to be
back traced in well let's read it and
find out how twisted and negative it is
as you know any criticism brian
cavanaugh encounters on the internet is
the result of a paid h3 bot every
instagram comment
twitter comment
is uh me or someone i'm paying
clearly
um
yeah there should be an a history tab
yeah i'm looking through it right now
i'm trying to see what was the name of
the user he kept saying was
it's i don't it's jk dot kite
yeah that
person isn't listed in the history for
some reason but you don't see he says
there's three users keep who kept trying
to add controversies
yeah
yeah i'm still looking
he says uh
most telling are the articles and posts
in question
come from sources that are three to ten
years old bro who says articles need to
be like posted yesterday
uh and oh and her only for the last 40
days they keep trying to adding the
section it's misleading as the press
they sources
and the very same articles state that
the allegations are proven false and
inaccurate and there's been dozens of
articles posted since then
refuting the claim so post those
articles dude what do you want
here we go
controvers uh so deleted uh controversy
dui details from new york times can you
put it up can you put it on the screen
i sent it in discord
okay
so
how has you getting a dui been refuted
ryan
can you
can you explain how you having a dui has
been refuted
oh
i can't see what people wrote of can you
see it dan no i'm trying to pull it up
you should be able to see it
okay dan's on it
yeah he's like listen the fact that i
got two duis has been long refuted
what the only part to raise these claims
and attempt to spend them as faces ethan
klein of h3 on the exact same dates
these editors keep trying i don't know a
decade old to three year old
three years old that's not even old
have all been publicly proven false okay
shut up dude you're such a whiny weirdo
looks like someone fixed it thank you
maybe you can advise as there's nothing
added since 2008 and a lot of press of
recent activities
it seems i shouldn't be adding things so
there's always a way to add source that
i don't know i i don't follow
oh
they found an old conversation of the
same user
okay wait i missed one here this cur
this user is blocked yeah so he got
banned
for threatening a mod with oh yeah here
it says this awesome
blocked
rk with an expiration time of indefinite
making legal threats
that's fun
how epic
okay
this is part of what got deleted
kavanaugh was arrested in 2008 eight for
driving with suspended license speeding
and drunk driving
for dui from an earlier convection
kavanaugh under a plea bargain
that disposed of an earlier case that
was placed on 36-month probation it's
not allowed to drive during that time
with any alcohol content in his
bloodstream and it is sourced
source number 29. new york times
so i'd like to see where he refuted the
the new york times article titled
hollywood financier is arrested again
again
in a bug
he got booked
by the way you want to talk about the
classism
wait what was the other part i want to
see the whole thing
what there was more controversies there
bring back that page okay
uh carrie metz a headphone investor in
20185 amended lawsuits saying that
kavanaugh defrauded him by conning him
into making a 10 million dollar
investment in relativity media in 2013.
also in 2015 while the company is near
bankruptcy that's alleged that kavanaugh
duped him into making another 2.5
million investment
new york bankruptcy judge michael wiles
dismissed aspects of his initial
complaint alleging preacher contract
enrichment of oral contract
blah blah blah blah blah
doesn't sounds like it was pretty fair
in terms of like part of it was debunked
variety relative relativity media
investor claims
so i haven't seen that that's a good
headline i haven't seen this one
1.5 million in fraud
yes so
you know what we should do post let's
let's post those excerpts for posterity
because somebody wrote those up lovingly
and i think it's a shame that ryan's
been able to get those removed so we
should we should copy that and post it
somewhere so people can read it
and if you guys are editors on wikipedia
or something you guys should this is
[ __ ] up you shouldn't bring it to
bring it to light you know
that this guy is doing this
oh there's a whole bigger part here wait
there's a bigger portion
i'm finding some notes from the editors
going back and forth
i just sent right here where says i
think ryan is paying multiple people to
save his page from the news
i added this after seeing the history of
the page was locked then i found the
sources for the new york times a variety
and then the mod saying yes i agree with
your assessment and i put back some of
the information that was removed but
then if you go to the page it's still
there's no controversies part
for example here it said in june 2019
variety magazine reporter ryan cavanaugh
was accused by his ex partner running a
ponzi scheme boom
done
in 2021 uh the trailer fight club ryan
oh oh that's about me ryan kevin engaged
in a legal battle
with ethan klein over copyright dispute
that's pretty normal that's just like
normal
nothing there
uh 2018 an article titled relatively
fabricated memo of claiming sexual
harassment
uh ryan kavanagh is accused of allegedly
fabricating the sexual harassment claims
and miranda
used against adam fields to justify
firing him without severance
that seems like important information to
have there
you know what i mean
and also this is great when a forensic
audit of relativity media was conducted
it was discovered that the author of the
uh memorandum
and uh
was signature stamped cav cav
why would you why would this be a race
from his page this is super relevant
information
this is information warfare
you know
it's just [ __ ] up
like if i go to his page right now
somehow he's managed to scrub it all
there's no controversies and that's just
all super well sourced
i'm f yeah i thought that's it that's
all i want to say you know
pretty interesting right that he got
banned from wikipedia though for
threatening the legal action against
state i'm a [ __ ] loser isn't that
awesome
that's awesome
oh and then another thing that happened
at the same time
was he's being suit this is so good he's
being sued
by bare-knuckle
boxing
for stealing their
international ip
isn't that ironic he's suing me for
copyright infringement and these
[ __ ] are like no
ryan's the guy who stole [ __ ] ip from us
and we're suing him
yeah without reading this whole thing
apparently
they have patented this uh triangle ring
i guess the ufc has patented the pen the
the octagon right yeah
and uh they owned that so i guess they
were in talks with ryan
about
about licensing out the triangle to them
patented trigon triangle-shaped fighting
ring
they said ryan kavanaugh
triller's owner they referred to him by
the way as ryan kavanagh over triller's
unauthorized and unlawful use of the
patented trigon
apparently they were in talks to
collaborate and then he's like okay cool
and then went on and used it without
their permission
that's [ __ ]
he said we've made numerous good efforts
to address the situation and protect our
proprietary design and intellectual
property rights
upon news coverage of the november 27
event we even promptly reached out to
triller my emails went unanswered and
our attorney's letter to trailer did not
seem to leave an impression
that's weird that they chose the
triangle that seems like weirdly
specific
doesn't seem very good if i'm going it
doesn't i don't even know why you'd want
to do that other than to [ __ ] with these
guys
just do a square dude
well anyway talk about ip theft right
kavanagh you're stealing ip you [ __ ]
hypocrite [ __ ]
stupid ass
stupid
so yeah
oh they even posted this
like promoting their like
their triangle here let's see
what she's gonna sue me for copper
infringement combat sports is coming in
[Music]
one year anniversary
we revealed
oh the trilogy oh yeah oh he's straight
up
oh
so he's like yo this is rip now
we own the triad
what a psycho
whoa
that's
crazy okay that explains the lawsuit
i gotta watch this again
you've seen the square
you've seen the octagon
we revealed
the triller triad
this is my battleground with new rules
new ring new equipment
the first truly revolutionary combats i
really like the high-end graphics
you know what right you definitely
deserve to get sued for this [ __ ]
and not just about how bad these [ __ ]
graphics are
but you definitely ripped them off dude
i don't want to tell you man you're such
a piece of [ __ ]
he might be the biggest piece of [ __ ] of
all time
holy god
i wonder if any of his like ex
business partners who hate his guts from
like uh
what the hell
from hollywood days are watching our
podcast and just loving
us dunking on him every week
so that's all i've got to say uh a quote
from the fight the people suing him
since 2015 we've invested a significant
amount of capital
into our triangle ring design the trigon
um
the fight promoter mike vasquez said in
a statement upon seeing trailers blatant
copy
of our patented ring design we made our
best efforts to communicate and resolve
the situant amicably yeah i did the same
thing unfortunately we're absolutely
rebuffed there you go
wait what is this oh
[ __ ] you guys want to hear more i don't
know if people are fatigued but a b had
a
okay av tell give us a little high level
recap and then the people can decide if
they want to hear it
um so i spoke to someone that was uh
screwed over by triller and copy and uh
it got pretty deep it got to the point
of blackmail according to this person
whoa and threads wait you titled it king
kong vs godzilla just title it
just title it keemstar vs the quarter
okay
you literally told me to title it that
no it didn't yes you did that was a
little that was your idea
i believe that was uh
someone else who said that i didn't say
that
also it's kind of like making fun of
them in a way i wouldn't want to do
anyway
i'm sorry i wasn't paying attention yeah
clearly
somebody wasn't paying attention
it was an interesting phone call yeah go
ahead uh go ahead no that was pretty
much pretty much i just opened the
stream and saw the title and i was like
wait what okay so do you guys want
to hear
the phone call obviously we can't give
details we can only give an anonymous
accounting
i typed something up and i checked with
this guy and he said it's okay to share
what i have right here okay awesome yeah
so guys do you want to hear it let's go
let's keep the cabin the kavanagh [ __ ]
going baby
uh let's do a vote
this is good stuff
looks like a lot of the chad wants to
hear it
it's short it's not it's not long roll
it
all right read it damn oh i thought you
were reading it okay um so
it's gonna be works i wrote it in third
person
i'll read it i'll
so let's see eight well i thought you
were just guys whatever av spoke to an
independent contractor
who was left
willfully unpaid by triller
despite no issue with their work
the contractor was on a payroll system
which stopped without cause
the contractor was told to continue
working by producers of proximity
proxima
media yo this is giving me like office
space
this is horrifying i'm getting like
horrified reading this a parent company
trailer uses presumably to deflect
litigation in their skin well he owned
he's the guy behind
proxima media right that's his business
yep
a producer from proxima
assured the contractor the the delay
the delay was a hiccup in accounting
this person has spoken to other people
who have gone through a similar process
with trailer whenever trying to recoup
money that was owed
this person claims triller
will withhold payments in these
situations until they are threatened
with lawsuits
forcing independent contractors to spend
legal fees to recoup income or just move
on
this anonymous source
received random blackmail threats
when asked for money owed from friends
of rank kavanaugh wait so can you unpack
that last part for me
yeah so this person received threats we
got random phone calls from friends of
ryan cavanaugh who
produced different threats about
him not finding work again in the
industry stuff along those lines
i've heard trump does a similar thing
but i guess there's really shitty people
in the world who this is actually like a
cost saving strategy of horribly [ __ ]
up businesses where they will employ
people
intentionally not pay them
because they have retainer they have
lawyers on retainer right
um
and then
a lot of the times most people will just
not even bother to sue them because it's
so expensive and costly
and uh this is actually a legitimate
[ __ ] the a strategy
of the worst people in the world to not
pay
bills
and funnily enough it's usually against
like hard working salt of the earth
people not like
you know ibm vs apple it's like you're
[ __ ] over
people who need the money
it's disgusting
yeah
and he's did he say that he knows other
people this happened to or yeah yeah he
did and he said in these other
situations seems like uh they won't even
respond unless you threaten legal action
how do you do that i mean that's just
that's pure it's like psychotic it
really is
[Music]
it's a shame that this country allows
people to do that i mean
that's [ __ ] insane
ah
this music's deep
custard cheeks you guys want to watch
that i love that video
yeah let's watch that
um the new
channel five was so good
it's still going a little viral for
i mean this video has been doing really
good lately but
um
this one's doing really good [ __ ] mac
did anyone watch this i did yeah so it
was probably good
so good
where does he find these people man i
gotta have bring andrew on to to ask him
some questions because
i don't know how the [ __ ] he finds these
people
the old english right here okay i'm
watching these streets also when these
weird ass [ __ ] in these cores [ __ ]
this [ __ ] ain't a game i like to let
[ __ ] know around the world to
get real tricky to get real mickey
you're real dangerous my god damn he
can't affect your fist trying to do
interview god great man i would but i'll
[ __ ] your wife custer
i'm gonna keep it 55th straight who's
custer a custer is a buster with a c i'm
a [ __ ] crib something nifty on
50s what does it mean to be a nifty you
tell a citch you want to bust her [ __ ]
an [ __ ] open you fight me and then
you have a nifty issue with her care if
i be gonna do nifty thanks in that motel
five with that six let's go ahead and
keep it fifty fair straight this 55th
street how long have you been hanging
out here for oh cuz i got put on cut i
was a teenager what does it mean to get
uh put on okay well i can take you an
alley one of y'all want to catch this
friendly fade with crepe mac nick wants
to get put on come on cuck i'm an alley
come on nick
come on nick
no custer [ __ ] come on
i fight anybody i don't give a [ __ ] on
neighborhood [ __ ] nick how do you feel
i'm a little nervous
you've never been put on all kind of
gotta do is fight back go nick swing
swing
swing
he's got the camera in his hand it's not
a fair play
maybe a [ __ ]
first [ __ ] video man to come in
the [ __ ] 55th street alley and
actually attempt a 55th street fake car
got more heart than all these other
custer ass
[ __ ] video people out here you
would have never made the cut i'm gonna
keep it 55th street but if you would
have stayed back it's all skyrim music
oh it is
it's like the battle music from skyrim
yo so this guy is such an interesting
character by the way
i don't i'm just so curious where he
finds these guys and i don't know man
it's pretty amazing
how he
has invented his own language like
unironically pretty impressive
and i love how the crips by the way
they they put the sea instead of bees
because blood right you you replace the
bloods with the seas
like i've heard and then also the bloods
do it they say you're going brazy
for crazy you take the c out you put the
b in
brazy barona virus bovin 19. bombton
bombton exactly
that's pretty clever actually
i like that [ __ ]
you're going crazy cuz
i don't know why they got to fight each
other like they're doing all this fun
stuff with like the letters it's like
cool
why can't they just have like a dance
battle
like do like it's just do like a
you just got served or something instead
of
shooting each other
cause look at like [ __ ] mack he's a good
nature guy dude
55th street
street fake i got more heart than all
these other custer ass
[ __ ] video people out here you
would have never made the cut i'm gonna
keep it fifty fifth straight but if you
would have stayed back here more
[ __ ] would have came you kept
on fighting as long as you get up and
keep fighting
on hood oh everything would have seen
all right okay you wouldn't adventure
you got put on we're gonna name them
dynamite blue dynamite blue because i
like the blue at the end of it in the
county jail you gang bang [ __ ] they're
gonna punch the [ __ ] out of you and
remember if you ever do a lot of time in
jail never commit suicide
thank you
breaking news breaking news
what do [ __ ] is that a joke or or
someone asked me what do crips
i was just curious what crips called
bees
they call them c's
it could be
i mean that'd be a question for [ __ ]
mack
true 55th straight keep it
yo check out these c's coming at you
it's funny because people it's probably
really confusing i mean it's really
confusing because
where's that sound
is that outside or upstairs oh [ __ ] i
think the crips and bloods came from oh
[ __ ]
yo get those custards out of here you
know i was in a play over the summer and
right before one of our performances the
bloods i guess like were filming some
sort of music video
and they all were dressed in
red and they smoked out the entire
theater and left popcorn everywhere hell
yeah that's what i'm saying this is
pretty cool they wanted the like these
people they don't need to fight they're
dope yeah i mean it's a complex system
to dismantle
blood because he says brazy i think
kendrick's blood right well i don't
think he's a member of a gang but he
comes from a blood neighborhood
because he uses the bee
yeah exactly
that's how i identify them that's cool
depends how they say custer and breezy
that's how you know if they're creep or
blood
and i'll tell you what dude these guys
have these clever words they use just
imagine if you put them together how
much clever kind of new language we
could make up and what kind of crazy-ass
parties we could have
you know there's no reason that kendrick
lamar and [ __ ] mack can't get along
be a great record that's what i'm saying
dude keep it 55th street
channel 5
with andrew callahan
whoa that's a lot of red bro you're
doing a video about a [ __ ] nah
that's intentional
it's all about having heart okay you
don't see scared of nobody bigger than
you i understand our neighborhood [ __ ]
look little babe bring that big [ __ ]
thing of water out that [ __ ] back of
that car lupe from 406 neighborhood
crips so she's from the photies right up
the street
oh lupe's a great woman she's an
assistant she helps me with a lot of
things out here how long have you guys
been together for we're not buying a
relationship really no okay that's my
driver i had no idea i thought you guys
were in a relationship bro
i'm his homegirl bro you know it's a
difference between stitches and
homegirls you know i don't gotta you
know wear his whistle or nothing like
that weigh his whistle is that a sexual
innuendo
mm-hmm what is what she said weigh his
whistle wet his weight oh wet his
whistle that makes sense
i thought weighing this is just a weird
act
not necessarily sexual
just like hmm
feels heavy today that is weird
okay wedding i mean she's gonna keep her
gripping her gang banging solid and
she's gonna stay snow she is they gonna
respect she gonna stay snooze she is i'm
trying to pick out all the [ __ ]
language but i don't think that was one
of them so like we respect lupe you
fight me who's the prettiest girl you
ever
uh you know did the thing with okay
pretty but that's that's hard look at
this a hard question yeah
uh we gonna answer this okay let's get
you took uh let's do uh
shaniqua shaniqua she is uh the top
and uh keep it 50 fair straight you find
me we'll do stacy mac what do you want
to be when you get like like what's your
what's your life goal shout out stacy
mack and shaniqua huge raise from great
mac
you know well i told you i want to own
the stuff i have the kids the gems and
[ __ ] some big booty beautiful stitches
they can ruin the program get back by
the community as i fly c5c5 but over
money i never gonna change i am new the
[ __ ] i am i'm gonna keep it 55th street
so wait when he says snoo the [ __ ] i am
is he doing something with like what's
he doing there
i am who i am i am snoo who i am what is
he doing there is that some kind of gang
thing
no clue that one's about my pick right i
don't know
he seems like such a sweet guy and you
will see that he actually is such a nice
guy interesting guy i do wonder how he
makes money i mean
does you think it's something illicit
because he seems like he has money he
just hangs out in the alley all day
drinking
it's got to be something illicit i'm
just assuming
yeah
i hope not though i hope it's above
board
for sure do you ever regret having any
of the face tattoos uh i'm gonna give
you a 55th street just to sit your name
on my face but all the gang whacked out
i love them i'm about them and they're
never coming off i don't give a [ __ ] you
got a million right now cub spit on that
[ __ ] neighborhood grip me and
lupe gonna go get our money out the mud
would you say that kids should stay in
school and not join gangs well
no kids we're gonna keep it fifteen
kids they should go to school this is
interesting
so it's an insult
towards the gang hoover
which is a faction of the crips usually
in the south
look at that [ __ ] ass snoover
so wait if they're part of the crips why
are we
i'm not sure there's
there's lots of different clicks within
both yeah it's a lot to keep track of
yeah
so okay wait i thought he was a blood
nope because he said
okay
okay so the hoover gang
is a fraction of the why are you making
fun of your own dudes
because he's 55th he's just trying to
keep it fit [ __ ] or nothing i guess
it's like you know shia and sunni
muslims we beef sometimes
i don't believe in it but damn because
andrew andrew needs to bring peace to
these neighborhoods i think he can do it
he's the jared kushner of
l.a gang wars oh my god
you can bring what what is this you sent
me olivia
people in the chat then oh people in the
chat were saying that my story about the
theater wasn't real so i sent the text
from when i was walking oh
people calling you a liar i said here
what is happening outside okay so olivia
sent receipts just in case you guys want
to call her out
that's when you're here there's like
random people's names on it i don't know
oh [ __ ] oh no they don't care i just
texted him
and they responded yes it did happen
okay this [ __ ] is nuts come around back
um and then he and then he says i wore
the wrong colors because he was wearing
blue yeah you don't want to [ __ ]
troll from blue to a crib or to a blood
party
that's weird because
blue
is blood
wait do you think that maybe i switched
i don't want to wear the blue no no the
crips wear the blue
yeah whichever the opposite are they
called the scripts called blue clue oh
my god i guess so
like a board game they call it because
the bloods should wear blue because they
got that bee in it true
oh the stage manager just texted me and
said they were all very nice about
having to clear out the theater so we
could rehearse exactly it's true they're
all nice good guys these are good guys
waking up right now this [ __ ] is nuts um
looking for yeah so whatever i believe
you obviously thank you thank you come
on
okay let's continue this is a lot we
have to analyze
we probably have some calls populating
too we'll get to those in a minute we're
way over for break too by the way
should i just let's just do that then
and we'll come back to the
all right very fair street all right
thank you to jen lock
awesome awesome
groundbreaking even
a new series on hbo max
the fate of an increasingly hostile
world world rests on five soldiers
bro can you just read
all right let's start let's try this
again
oh that looks that looks sick
give you a little idea
visual style the mine is a powerful
weapon but who really is in control the
groundbreaking hbo max series gen lock
the fate of an increasingly hostile
world rests on five shoulders shoulders
soldiers who upload their minds to giant
mech warriors
giant mecca war machine
you don't even have to think about it
dude i think there's actually a note not
to complain i know that's why i [ __ ]
up
giant mecca war machines executive
produced and starring michael b jordan
season 2 of this action-packed animated
series is now streaming on hbo max 50
years into the future a global
extinction event ravages earth
isn't that happening now
indeed
that's awesome
war it's like the most com okay whatever
let's not go on tangier war rages
between the union and the polity
polity
who hold very different ideas on how to
save humanity as territories follow the
union's charismatic leader preaches
about a higher
existence for all of mankind the gen
lock team is the pull
[Applause]
greatest weapon utilizing advanced
technology they upload their minds to
weaponized robotic suits to combat the
union forces let's [ __ ] go let's go
this team of fighters will soon learn
that digitizing their minds can leave
them more shell shocked than the
battlefield as their darkest thoughts
become reality whose war are they
fighting and at what cost the heart
pounding new season of gen lock features
a star-studded voice cast including
michael b jordan dakota fanning maisie
williams
asia kate
dillon
and david tennant
jenn locke
season two is now streaming on hbo max
humanity will prevail
made it through that one hey nailed it
honey
we all shop online especially now you're
coming on black friday thanksgiving you
don't want to be
on the internet
without a honey condom
it's protection
[Music]
uh we've also seen that promo code tonta
said check out but thanks to honey
manual searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping but so thank god okay
thank god
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo coz that
applies the best one it finds to your
car honey supports over 30 000 stores
online ranging from tech gaming products
to popular fashion brands and even food
delivery
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites when you check out the
honey button drops down and all you have
to do is click apply coupons wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
you can find for that site if honey
finds a working coupon you'll watch that
price drop as we did here
with this one you listen yeah you've
been racking them up lately yeah so this
is what happens i mean
you just save money for nothing you're
just on your favorite website graph
lance
[Music]
it's it's literally insane how much
money you save without even thinking
about it just automatically applies
coupons it's so good
well said it saved its 17 million
members over two billion dollars so if
you don't already have honey you could
be straight up missing out on free
savings literally free
installs in a few seconds and by getting
it you'll be doing yourself a solid and
supporting this podcast
i use it i love it get honey for free at
jointhoney.com h3tv that's
jointhoney.com
h3tv thank you
oh
what happened
check it out
oh we got does they erase our dislike
button dislikes are gone
interesting it happened finally happened
guys sorry haters yeah
only i can look at it and cry now right
my dashboard
the end of an era
the dislike that's sad
that's sad
it's interesting
very interesting
some might say
fascinating
uh thank you to raycon
it's never too early to start gift
shopping for the holidays especially
because today you can save
big on a gift they're going to use
everyday their weight the raycon
wireless earbuds
okay
now
we've been using the raycon around the
office
dan's been using it i've been using it
different earbuds gross
i don't like it's okay you can share
that we use them communally i don't like
wax don't be embarrassed here
i don't like it let everybody know you
and i we don't share raycons
that's right bud we don't we do you're
like why are you so embarrassed to admit
this because we don't bro
stop lying on me
custer
you're a buster here's the deal with
race i mean the quality of i have other
the normal ones that everyone's got you
know the big boy ones
sounds just as good
it's more comfortable
that's it that's all it is bro you know
working from home
doing a workout going for walks
listening without disturbing you know
it's got it all with seamless bluetooth
wire pairing and comfortable noise
isolating fit you can start listening
right away and keep listening for hours
the audio quality is amazing comparable
what you get from other premium brands
except raycon starts at literally half
the price
the new everyday earbuds come with three
new sound profiles as well to make sure
that whatever you're listening to sounds
the best we've got pure mode balanced
mode bass mode you know what it is
raycon offers eight hours of play time
and 32 hours of battery life there's
also a built-in mic so you can take
calls on earbuds at the press of a
button so this holiday season get them
something they can use for calls for
music for work or play or at home or on
the go
or pick one up for yourself trust me
you're gonna use them every day you're
gonna love them
do you have a can we show it yeah abs
holding it oh yeah yeah they come in
this awesome pouch to recharge it
you know go to bed
you pop them in that's the same pair of
ethan and bro
oh hell yeah bro we're i don't know
it's disgusting
uh go to buy raycon dot com slash h3
today to unlock exclusive deals of up to
20 off your raycon order but hurry this
offer is only available for a limited
time on you don't want to miss it that's
by raycon dot com slash h3 to unlock up
to 20 percent off your recons
by raycom.com
h3 thank you
[Laughter]
all right back to i gotta pee
and i'm so hungry you guys
i'm starving and it's thanksgiving week
you know what it means what do you want
what do you want you want turkey can we
get a turkey yeah i want a turkey no i
want [ __ ] turkey on my pizza
[Music]
do you guys even like turkey i feel like
it's overrated as [ __ ] i always hated
turkey i mean obviously i don't eat it
now there's a reason people only eat it
once a year because it sucks i was the
only one last year on the cast who
didn't hate thanksgiving
i
i guess that still holds true olivia do
you like thanksgiving i don't hate it i
like that i mean i just don't think
i think we said that we don't think
thanksgiving food is very i love
thanksgiving maybe that's what it was
yeah yeah i requested a steak this year
oh that sounds good yeah that's some
baller [ __ ] right there i'm like i ain't
eating any [ __ ] turkey that's crazy i
like
that the sides are good
even though i don't think so i don't
know some are okay well i like green
beans i like mashed potatoes and gravy
sure potatoes is like cranberries
i really like cranberries cranberry
sauce is like okay who gives a [ __ ]
i do i love it i like it it all makes
you feel [ __ ] tired
yeah and then you get to have a good
night can you guys tell me which
neighborhood
is my neighborhood in a [ __ ] or a blood
area where i live i don't i think the
kings are over there
yeah i think that's where the royal
palace is actually a joke about this
kind of stuff that's climb territory
what do you mean i just want to know if
i need to say brave you know what i am
with jen i retract my statement
peace and love about what
talking about this stuff
what i shouldn't talk about crips and
bloods i mean you're good
but you're not
wait i'm not in a gated community
do you think [ __ ] mac's coming for you
delete me from this conversation
what shaq said
all right let's keep watching i do have
to pee though and also what about food
what do you guys want let's take a vote
right [ __ ] now
what do you want
what do i want it's not how a boat works
okay
okay let's take a vote if you have a
speak up dan
let's
get some
freaking
oh mexican food
interesting
what do you want olivia you seem
disappointed by that um
it's just because we had breakfast
burritos earlier you guys have breakfast
burritos without me was were they no we
didn't
what we did
right um
we could do like sandwiches soups
sandwich is good i like sandwich let's
do sandwich okay sandwiches [ __ ]
fried chicken lock that [ __ ] in
yeah i like sandwich people demanding
pull you guys don't get a say in this
yeah you think you get a saying we don't
need to prolong this
didn't last week they voted what we
should eat and then we decided against
what they didn't even listen to them
we stopped the vote after two people
okay i gotta pee for real though i'll be
here you have any skin in the game here
people
okay somebody donated fifty dollars just
and said how do i make my message go on
the video
well that's twitter send 50 more dollars
we'll tell you i don't
know which
is that twitch
maybe that's what they're thinking of
like a pop-up thing we don't we don't
have those i'm sorry if that was your
intention but i'm reading your comment
right now and i'm addressing you
directly i'm looking right in the camera
and talking specifically to you nnn rrr
so
thank you for the 50 donation big ups
wait did you you need to donate 500
before it shows oh they donated another
50
nice again earlier and said hey
can you restock teddy fresh it's like
you only have one two xl in stock and
you always drop it at 3am when i'm
sleeping well i got you dude i'll
restock it real quick
i have some more unfortunate news we
don't actually work at teddy fresh
uh it is a separate company we're not
really involved with
so um there's not a whole lot that we
can do
50 50 straight now that said
um
i'm sure that they will restock after
this uh black friday sale is over with i
think that's probably why you're having
a hard time right now because everything
is deeply discounted teddybridge.com
uh my maga mother-in-law attempts to
give me covet and ebola during the
holidays and you guys hang up on me
sorry
what does that mean the calls always
drop
oh we're talking about oh the call-in
gotcha yeah it's probably not
intentional it's just our system yeah
there's so many people or maybe your
story just
wasn't very good
55th straight
uh
rogue
donated aed 184.99
with the question how much is this in
your country well
it's like let's find out to
us
oh that's about 50 bucks so that's a
pretty good donation that's from that is
uh
durham's from the uae so thank you for
the
184.99 durham's thank you so much
so the currency from the uae
yeah
here we have another donation from kirby
nine nine that says dan has pretty eyes
i agree oh thank you
that's so sweet
from united arab emirates fifty bucks oh
oh fifty bucks thank you
uh there is a fifty dollar donation
oh that same person also donated 20 hey
man how do i write some message to the
podcast you don't
i feel bad you you're throwing a lot of
money in here
asking questions that you already have
the solution to we're we're seeing it
we're seeing your message you don't have
to you're doing it right you don't need
to keep donating money
i love you for that we do love you for
that
but i i can't help but feel a little bad
well
oh somebody hold on one last one ten
dollars shea says zach and his dad came
into my restaurant yesterday if you all
ever come in lunch is on me is that did
you go did you and your dad go out to
eat yeah it was actually posted on the
sub she was she was very nice oh i saw
that yeah i didn't know it was you and
uh
daddy yeah yeah can i say his name or
should i not you've said it before yeah
daddy todd yeah yeah todd todd tuck
poster
yeah she was very nice um shout out did
your dad ever see any of the things i
said about him like the todd and talk
yeah i wonder what he thought about that
he thought it was funny
yeah because his dad is a realtor and he
showed me a few houses we'd end up doing
anything with him but he would show up
all tucked in like a chub and tuck he's
not fat but he just got a little todd
we're we're building
us burn scenes are big people so um
i can confirm
uh
one last one somebody donated 20 bucks
alex will 20 bucks get you to say happy
birthday to jordan it's tomorrow she's a
huge fan of you all and just got her
first teddy fresh you guys are always on
in our house jordan
happy birthday i don't think she would
happy birthday jordan
oh you didn't birthday jordan well they
donated while you were gone
go ahead everybody
everybody the rest of us are on cameo
what the [ __ ]
we're barred from that
wait you're barred from seeing your
cameo i don't know i just feel like it's
not appropriate thing to do when do we
get bored when is av ever shied away
from mentioning this cameo i just feel
like i'm literally the least one these
guys have plugged it both i have not
said it you are you are a stereotyping i
just banned you guys from plugging your
cameo okay when did i ban you you never
in my head you did in my head you did
what what i just don't throw me into i
never banned you guys i just feel like i
don't know it would be kind of a did i
ever ban you guys from mentioning no
never no never no okay i just i just
want to be respectful
you plugged it for us multiple times
you have now we are and now you guys are
now we're talking about cameo
what are you what are you hitting there
it's one of the uh leftover coffees
oh it's a coffee yeah okay
all right
there's one in there called pop and
bottle
you know what i'm glad you clarified
because i don't want people to think i'm
right just drinking a beer midday
well it's afternoon
it's just coffee oh the dude from the
uae donated
again and said can i get a refund now
that i know that it's 50 bucks
no
i don't think that's in our uh i don't
think we have the power to refund we do
not have to take that up with your
credit card right
yeah that's all through youtube sorry
all right shall we continue
someone order some damn sandwiches
uh sam says she's on it okay get me a
good ass one because lena and elon here
sam you got that give me a good fight
good ass sandwich something like real
dirty and [ __ ] up you know what i'm
saying
keep it 55th street real dirty and
[ __ ] up
she said i'ma get you that good [ __ ]
yeah let me ah she says you're gonna
keep a fitty fist
colony get me a colony sandwich
that's bologna with a c
i'm the blood or a [ __ ] sorry sorry
oh yeah i think bella i think bel air is
in the um
i think it's part of the [ __ ] hood
you don't like that joke then
why i think it's funny
i don't know growing up here it was it
was instilled in me to to not [ __ ]
around with bloods and crips so this
whole this whole joking on them thing is
making me laugh well let's see just
because i've seen that how nice a guy
this guy is a family
[Music]
kind of a rehabilitation program for
ex-gang members
yeah and they work in the bakery and
make all kinds of food right yeah and
it's all ex-cons is it good it's
probably bomb yeah it actually is yeah i
worked there for a second you worked
there yeah she's an ex-con
which gang were you part of grove street
right
uh the bloods obviously no oh no i just
worked there a little bit before i got
my needle exchange job
needle exchange yeah we talked about
this i feel like i don't know you worked
at a needle exchange no i worked at uh
homeless healthcare los angeles in the
needle exchange what are you some kind
of saint how did you end up here
i don't want to fall from home i i did a
program when i was in high school so we
visited home boys
that's gregary and chance for you for me
yeah
olivia oh my god tell us about your time
in the needle exchange um
i mean i loved it i worked there for
almost three years on and off
i did a program in high school
where we visited a bunch of grassroots
activism places
i really loved
the needle exchange when i was there i
loved what they did
you just liked the
you liked the work you thought it was
good
yeah i it it was
their full why is everybody giggling at
me
but but this is a this is a very nice
story yeah keep going
um
their philosophy is they
treat every person as a person so
if they're gonna shoot up which they are
we
provide them clean needles and then when
they choose to get clean we also have
detox hey come on kenneth we're talking
they're actually trying to prevent
people from getting viruses yeah this is
hiv aids correct
kenneth
kenneth uh
bloapland kenneth boplin kenneth
no
don't make this a thing please
so so basically
do people bring in their old needles in
exchange so you get rid of the bat the
bad needles you give them the good
needles who how's it funded is it like a
government program or yeah it was
government funded they're actually
probably a city initiative
yes they i know that they were losing
funding so they were nervous about
losing their spot but i drove by the
other day and it's still there you need
more apcs for the lapd so i understand
why they would refund a program like
that yeah a lot of people
uh
kill them but if the police kill them
they don't need nothing oh they don't
need to shoot up anymore it's costly
that's a good point
yeah a lot of people were attacking the
root of the problem exactly because the
cops would hang out and skid row and
just arrest every person they could they
shortened the street lights for when
people would cross the streets and they
had huge carts they would they wouldn't
make it all the way across the street
and then they would use that as an
excuse to whoa
that's really interesting that you knew
about some of the
well yeah because people would come in
like tweaking because they were in jail
they couldn't use and then they would
come in
and get needles so that they could use
again
now did you ever get real close with any
of the addicts and just kind of learn
about them because i'm sure there's yeah
probably a lot of interesting stories
around there i didn't get like super
close with a lot of people but a lot of
people would um
see me there because most of the people
i worked with were ex-gang members or
ex-users and they would always just be
like do not ever do drugs oh wow
take it from them
it's not okay no it was it was sad but
it was it was also
it was a cool job
you know
it's real
it's crazy when you think about how all
those places intersect and kind of how
we spend our money
like
in the city of l.a we spending what like
50 of the budget on police dan is that
right or is it less than that oh forget
the stat but it's like billions billions
it's a lot it's a lot it's a lot and so
just imagine like you should be spending
money on prevention
i mean if you take a billion dollars out
of the police budget
and spend it on prevention
you're not going to need those police to
[ __ ] please skid row social services
in general yeah that's kind of the trend
over the last 40 years or so is to
shut down all of these social services
and then redirect those funds into more
and more policing
yeah because what they're trying to do
is they're trying to like sweep the
streets and like get rid of people but
you have to address homelessness before
you temporarily house people in jail
it's really crazy right
it's so sad like
poli like and police are so expensive
too you know it because it's personnel
it's insurance they need like body armor
and weapons like police is one of the
most expensive [ __ ] things you can
employ
and if you're talk and then these people
on the streets need so little
uh
to be put in a good situation like one
cop
how much that costs the state just to
employ one cop
200 000 a year probably
maybe less i don't know
at least a hundred thousand
uh probably more
hundred thousand dollars a year
149 000. there you go 150 000. do you
know how much how much work that could
do on the actual
to prevent crime at the root of it
anyway back to [ __ ] mack
by themselves but you can't say every
kid not going gang bang because a lot of
kids want to do this [ __ ] oh this was
important i want to go back
straight
on my face but all the gang whack outs i
love them i'm about them and they're
never coming off i don't give a [ __ ] you
got a million right now cub i'm gonna
spit on that [ __ ] neighborhood
grip me and lupe gonna go get our money
out the mud would you say that kids
should stay in school and not join gangs
well kids we're gonna keep it 55th
street uh kids they should go to school
they should take care of their faith
family do [ __ ] find themselves but you
can't say every kid not going gangbang
because a lot of kids want to do this
[ __ ] you gotta by the way he said do
stuffs five yourself that's [ __ ] sick
for yourself no no no five yourself
oh i see
that's clever i like it the guy's got
his own like
verbal identity i mean who does that
that's sick he's smart i get prepared on
neighborhood crap watch this car right
here lupe you gotta park closer five
feet closer just snow creep max this is
not a [ __ ] game some people
drink alcohol and they don't drink no
water
that will kill you you gotta eat you
gotta drink water cabbie fire you drink
it's not rocket science [ __ ]
stay in school
okay wait there's a lot to decode here
hang on
some people drink alcohol and they don't
drink no water
that will kill you you got to eat you
got to drink water cabbie fire you drink
it's not
he says cuz
b5 okay so before the five we get that i
like that
because
just know [ __ ] max said this is not a
[ __ ] game some people drink
alcohol and they don't drink no water
that will kill you
that's [ __ ] good it's good advice i
mean straight up you got to eat you got
to drink water cabbie fire your drinks
cuz but five you drink not rocket
science
in [ __ ] do sports get back five
the community at the county say your
heart is you fight c5 c5 central 55th
straight
he's a beautiful person he's a beautiful
person he's always helping me he comes
by to see if i need anything you know i
see i i i'm disabled a lot of times she
come by and he i don't have the money to
get the parts i need from my weed eaters
and lawn mowers you know because
somebody stole my lawn mower
come by and got me wheatied you know and
i appreciate him you know i really do
and uh he's a very good person he's a
benefit to the neighborhood but he's
very intelligent you know and he has
ideas you know he's a business-minded
man what are some of the ideas he has
that you that you like the value of life
itself your liberty in where the next
man's liberty began and i've cried many
days right here
you know because i lost a lot of
homelessness a lot of loved ones you
know i'm i'm a firefighter neighborhood
[ __ ] and i have no enemies
but uh you can make me your enemy if you
do something to me our neighbors who
have they don't have to accept us but we
have to accept them but when i see them
i know life has got it i know god got it
[Music]
he just gets a [ __ ] a gang banger see
that's where they get [ __ ] [ __ ] up
[ __ ] got a problem with the media
enemies through the gang [ __ ] but then
people downtown the people that's
homeless kind of don't gang banging the
babies and innocent people they don't
got [ __ ] to do with these politics we do
all your kids
yeah so
this guy is legitimately such a good
dude he
i'm touched by the story of [ __ ] mack
i really am
i'm i'm so touched by his story and the
people out there just seem like actually
like good also good natured i don't mean
he just seems like a sweetheart ma'am
what'd you like
god check me pizza god says you need
pizza hell yeah god bless you
and remember
never commit suicide
everything gonna see all right
[Music]
by the way it's got there's like it's
kind of funny just going up to a random
person and being like don't commit
suicide it's a presumption but it's
actually
also really sweet
it says mantra that you'll notice
throughout the video he says don't
commit suicide
and it's just i mean it's nice that he
he cares about that thing it makes me
wonder more about
um if he's had someone close to him do
that or if he's ever had ideations
himself because he seems passionate
about that idea of not
not ending your own nobody
is better than anybody out here
we are all equal
as people hey sir
tacos over there
give you some free tacos
and remember
never commit
suicide
every day
all right i'm gonna keep it 55 straight
how often do you do this i do it every
sunday we got tacos with you
and taco every sunday this [ __ ]
comes out to skid row and cooks free
tacos for people
that's some crazy [ __ ] dude
damn a lot of tacos it means a lot you
know why like i said nobody's better
than nobody how many people have you
guys served here today so far like fifty
fifty two hundred this is wow yeah it's
called the five people right here
it's a youtube show called channel 5.
good you fight me
i wonder if the reason why [ __ ] mack
agreed to do this interview is because
it was channel 5
because it's 55th street i mean
it very well could be because i i had
made that connection myself and it's
like you must like that he doesn't seem
like the type of guy to [ __ ] with
this [ __ ] but here he is maybe it was a
sign to him yeah channel five
i had a family mom died you just got to
keep your head held up high you never
know okay you could have a great day
some [ __ ] like this there's something
mickey happy enemy wait okay he said
something mickey happened
someone know what that means
i don't know i don't know something
mickey happened
mickey mouse something weird maybe
maybe chat chat apparently understands
this [ __ ]
semi-yellow and chat understand every
gang
vernacular anyone want to give a shout
out an explanation on mickey something
i'm guessing it means something invalid
or fake is someone could uh slip the
mickey which means slip something into
your drink
but something that is not clear it's a
i'm seeing that it's a drug
something mickey happened
oh but that's an adjective yeah
interesting
something make you happy
mickey mouse i think people are saying
they're just like cheesy
mickey mantle it's like dosing someone's
what i'm saying like something mickey
mickey equals rat equals snitch says
somebody in the chat okay so something
just bad something snitchy happen
people are making okay i'm apparently
middle class because i don't understand
what mickey and
yeah i mean you're right i i'm not i'm
not from the [ __ ]
are you from the hood you're right i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna claim to be hood
i mean
i see mickey equals whack mickey equals
trouble something fake people are saying
yeah fake yeah okay thank you guys
thank you to my hood fans
oh someone's saying that uh adam 22
introduced [ __ ] mack to andrew so that's
so shout out adam 22 for
bringing us this uh video i guess
feeding them might say what you're dead
i'm just spit on you i don't give a [ __ ]
about these cameras i'm gonna knock her
asleep i'm gonna do destruction i'm
literally on my man i'm crazy i mean a
lot of people can see it it's not have
you always been crazy i think since i
was younger what age you thinking i
think granny bear will say about uh
10 or 12 years old around that what kind
of stuff dude do you think we could get
[ __ ] mac for an interview because
actually i want to go into like actual
details about some of the things in his
andrew i mean you got the connect i feel
like that would be a fascinating [ __ ]
interview don't you
long form interview sure i'm gonna text
him right now
i love [ __ ] mac i want to talk to him
more
you know because we're trying to think
of people to interview and i just i want
to talk people that i'm interested in
not like you get on this pr thing and
you're like oh that's someone that
people know bring them in and you know i
just don't care
like let's be real
i want to talk to people that i'm
actually interested in
he's on youtube and cameo as well [ __ ]
max on cameo
yo can we get one from let's go can we
get one from can i get can i guess how
much he charges
55. let's see
wait what no that that's just my guess
oh well somebody tells us
he's charging a lot holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] max sling and mia's
slinging mia's
his name is uh
[ __ ] mack 55
so
300 damn whoa i was close don't play
games 300 300 [ __ ] crap man i can't
i was like so confident it was gonna be
fifty five how could it not be fifty
five it would have been more like fifty
four nine eight nine
maybe he jumped it
he might have jacked it up after wait no
jumper already interviewed him damn he
beat me huh
well yeah i mean that was i guess we
just said that that's how andrew heard
about him so how how is it that people
know about him
local legend he's a rapper and is a
rapper i guess
he is oh okay
well anyway [ __ ] up
see this vid interview is for 50 minutes
i'm gonna do like a three hour extension
you know
no rock under you know
i don't think there's
yeah i think it's fine if somebody else
interviewed him i'm not even gonna watch
no jumper you see
you see
people make fun of me for being a bad
interviewer
it's just
when i talk to someone i'm actually
interested i'm the best interviewer of
all time okay and i'm just putting that
out there so people will say it and then
you all will start believing it
manifesting it manifesting a manifesting
destiny my interviewing skills no no
i've always thought you're one of the
best
well zach i love you for that you are
definitely had some slam dunks like
where i've re-watched a couple times
just really amazed yes thank you
i feel like sometimes it's i mean
obviously i've had some really horrible
interviews
but um i feel like
it's it's the thing about interviews
it's definitely developed skill you know
at first
it's not easy but let's [ __ ] reach
out try to reach out to [ __ ] mack i
genuinely want to get his ass in here
like first thing after the break and the
other person i really want to interview
is nicoto
[ __ ] fascinating dude
i've emailed him i've tweeted him i
don't know i gotta get
i gotta get this guy no response from
any of that
i mean he knew about
us
talking about him on the podcast like
immediately if he's not responding i
wouldn't well well i just need to i just
want to put a message to him that first
of all is not a gag i'm fascinated by
you i want to do like a real [ __ ]
like everything you do is so interesting
i just i want to know who you are and i
have a genuine discourse with you i'm i
i just i really think we could do a an
awesome show together
that's why i want to talk to you
okay
well thank you guys to everyone who's
saying that
uh you like my interviews
[Applause]
all right continue on and then if you
guys can find [ __ ] max contact let's
reach out but i also texted andrew i
have his instagram
i'll try that oh yeah baby
yes
i started happening around that time
well just uh was going back in fifth
with a mama bear's boyfriend then i got
him some snuggle what kind of trouble
were you getting into super early
get rid of uh
ding dong ditch as a kid did you do that
when you was a kid but uh
so i am [ __ ] a gangster
i was doing the same [ __ ] this guy was
[ __ ] i'm hard to spot
maybe let's let him complete this
thought for you he said thing i'm just
telling you bro i'm from the streets
that's true in another house i can fight
me like back and forth i could go fight
jail do a gang of time cup and have
nowhere to i got this down here these
people are also people okay as i fly
c5c5
and so i got something good going on
from the bottom of my heart hey sir
never commit suicide
everything going to see all right would
you like a slice of pizza oh no there it
is what about five later you're gonna
get hungry later
maybe after a couple beers or something
i don't think i'm a diabetic all right
well what about a pizza later when you
get hungry take it
oh it's not rocket science
[Music]
yeah never commit suicide never commit
suicide things get rough don't give up
don't take your own life everything but
if you guys
see all right girl never commit suicide
you know there's a concert happening
nearby
um no i don't pay attention to the
concerts and [ __ ] like that that what
you were interested in it's a heavy
metal band called slipknot you want to
go to slipknot uh what what what do they
stand for they stand for a hard rock
metal music
they're from iowa they're like uh i'm
meeting some of some new um you know
nice white ladies with a nice ass let's
go i know they got some white citrus
there you go white stitches you know
we take the b out we put the c in
that's that [ __ ] life [ __ ] because
no good
we have to mute this part cause oh it's
got slipknot music in
[Music]
i find it interesting andrew just
doesn't give a [ __ ] about like getting
claimed
it's kind of risky though
didn't get removed
nine guys that really just don't give a
[ __ ] pound music to their [ __ ] core
[ __ ] give it to their fans give it to
the maggots every [ __ ] day you know
they've got that loyal team they got
that just that drive to want to produce
music that they love and that the fans
love they don't give a [ __ ] what anybody
thinks about them just like me i got
hoover killer chatted on my
[ __ ] head
i
don't
[Music]
energy their life because they have a
passion for this music like no other
[ __ ] band how many big booty stitches
have you [ __ ] off of this mute this
good music
uh at least five oh goddamn actually i
have
travis scott tattoo it's the cactus jack
logo in russian
all right get up out of here
yeah that's the best take ever by [ __ ]
mack actually because we all knew like
that it's corny to get cactus jack
tatted but he goes you got another man's
name tatted on the side of your body
good point [ __ ] mac way to put it in
terms we can understand to go good with
some um some great lyrics so does that
get put on in and out of jail been my
life stop banging fly to set young
husbands going wow smashing anything
that is shrimp and hood me and my locks
up to no good what do you like about
sleeping
pure aggression just violin they don't
give a [ __ ] what nobody thinks nope
i like slipknot i don't do no custard
[ __ ] if you end your life you want
custard [ __ ] never take your own life
never take your own life listen five
great mac never take your own life big
suicide killer everything goes right
imma keep it fifty fair straight
fire fire all right well stop this is
actually exciting
i'm hoping we can get uh
[ __ ] mac into the the studio
yeah that dance is pretty fire actually
too
he does it much better
andrew actually linked how to contact
him in the description so
oh he did for sure yeah and he says his
price for interviews and everything whoa
i gotta pay him let's go i gotta pay him
it's probably expensive seeing his damn
um
seeing his damn uh
uh
cameo price right olivia's probably
right 550 bucks
interview
i pay that
andrew brought him back for his merch
drop video and some of his other meals
yeah dude his merch video is so good
like andrew serves it on everything bro
and
yeah his merch video goes so hard notice
hold on i want to see
what's his what's the details here
um
i sent a screenshot and discord
wait it doesn't oh oh what it started
showing it on the right how weird
interviews are 700 bucks
damn let's go okay yeah i would happily
pay him for that i respect that you know
most people comment well it's obviously
i consider interviews to be like uh
how do would you say it's symbiotic a
mutual exchange yeah
but you know what [ __ ] it you know [ __ ]
mac don't don't pee without getting paid
and i respect that
[ __ ] mack is currently off instagram
but he'd give you a special message he's
currently doing interviews for 700
features for 500 and zoom interviews for
200 bucks
mac five five at gmail
let's book him
his instagram says lady trisha runs this
page until cmac free
i'm guessing this is old because like
the last problem
is free yeah he's been freed
oh yeah look at all the claims poor
andrew got on this [ __ ]
rip to andrew's monetization again i'm
just afraid that they just block it
because i should they do that [ __ ] all
the damn time
you know
all right let's get chris mack in here
700 is easy
easy decision
um
i gotta check out his cameo i wonder if
he's got any i sent the link for it if
you want to check it out and discord
yeah so
two 250 huh let's see what he will see
what we got fans fans it's a beautiful
day we live in a beautiful world oh look
it's your little prep mac
from that 55th street oh hood y'all
tapping with me get your videos your
messages this is my cameo i'm five
minutes i'm giving back by the community
and remember when things are going bad
all right
so let's see what you got
aidan
[Music]
cameos fix your [ __ ] why you play two
videos at once
aidan
aiden
aiden
aiden oh [ __ ] aiden
oh hood
you are doing great
you're doing great things
dad and jenna are very proud of you man
continue
do great things in school
you're a young man just like famous fat
hood
you're young and you're ready to go
get in some sports do great things
mama
well jenna i apologize for slipping on
my cripping kid oh
daddy jenna
i'm very proud of you this is awesome
that's a good ass pep talk though to be
honest
you know it's inspiring oh he's in the
dark in these ones yo
[ __ ] you just got beamed by face
splitter thanks by the kids walking
locker looking this one's just a threat
cameo does this new thing where it fades
from black that's why it looks oh i was
like man that'd be awesome if he's just
doing it in like the
[ __ ] yeah this one's in the dark your
people they [ __ ] miss you
adam your brother cub misses you on hood
and i see
seeing the max seeing the overkill of
destruction [ __ ] mack makes you happy
just remember
everything is going to see all right
i like it i gotta talk to chris mack
we need him in the studio i'll pay him
i'll pay him up front cash double triple
it
anything
you guys want to watch his merch drop i
mean like
it's so epic and you always [ __ ]
deliver man
look at this [ __ ] did you watch his
merch video dan
it goes so hard
he got like all of the memes from all of
his previous videos this year
to do a video he must be selling it like
crazy because this video is so good
probably the best merch video i ever
seen
is straight content dude
you got the whole gang
look at this [ __ ] paul channel 5 blazers
come on now
good morning america i'm your host
andrew callahan and you're watching
channel 5 news we have a breaking story
channel 5 is now selling t-shirts and
more online [ __ ] the authority channel 5
news
is this going to get me claimed do you
think or is that maybe
that's a shame
yeah andrew doesn't give a [ __ ] i'll
play any music we can still buy t-shirts
from channel 5. get down willie brown
channel 5 worldwide live
yeah yeah it's i'm afraid to play it
because i don't want to get clean but
it's full of all this good [ __ ] dude
straight up let's just here play this
these two together are awesome
party with all of my killers
wow so i'm sitting here with a bonafide
gangster do you think maybe i can be an
honorary gangster
you could come hang out and party with
luke
you could come hang out the hell isn't
anyone doing their job in this
administration i'll let you know why
electric butterfly they're all custard
what's a custard a custard is a buster
with a c why did he use a c i'm a crab
makes complete sense it's not rocket
science electric butterfly trump kept it
55th street but now he's a [ __ ]
custer too
do you understand how insane this is a
maga cult is hanging out with a [ __ ] and
they're getting on well that's the magic
of andrew bro he's bringing peace to the
streets and everything in between
andrew for president this is insane this
is a queuing on cold disc chilling with
kurt mack
and they they're like cool
trust he could never see a crib [ __ ] him
if you seriously
want to stop the tyranny then start by
purchasing a channel five t-shirt and
where the [ __ ] out of it yeah again you
know energy is just doing he's doing a
new thing man it's crazy what he's doing
it's awesome
it's awesome
all right let's talk about keemstar and
quartering you know
okay this is one this is one of my
favorite things that happened on the
internet recently you'll
you love to see it
keemstar
and the quartering two of my favorite
people on the internet and i'm not
involved i just get to watch the
fireworks
i gotta pee again though oh my god
so damn
you got any donations
uh yeah um
somebody donated five dollars and said
if you can please interview the guy from
birds aren't real i
anybody know what that is
i do not
conspiracy movement oh
okay the birds are like ciao that
they're like robots
yeah
well
that's actually only the second weirdest
conspiracy theory that i've heard today
so what's the first
it's a video that we have coming up in
the dock a little bit here somebody who
believes that um ancient rome
is a
uh made-up
uh conspiracy it's mickey didn't yeah
check out h3tv discord and talk about
jfk resurrection q and on t i'm begging
you're begging
well if you beg
uh is it the thing now they're now a
literal
death cult and talking about how they
need to transcend
their physical bodies
because yes i did hear about that and uh
it's pretty scary
uh
what else we got
talk about glendon cameron a youtuber
who admit
to having
xrsx relationsh with a 17 year old girl
and keep bragging about it that he won't
get caught it's barf face
um i don't know anything about that but
yeah sounds sounds pretty barf face my
dude
trey melendez donated 50 bucks this is a
message for a b
i can't help but feel hurt
that i wasn't let into your twitter
space last night oh you did a twitter
space i did i complimented you by the
way i said some nice things about you
where the [ __ ] was i i usually don't
talk about the show on instagram but
this was like a new audience i was on
twitter and i was like they're like oh
you're the best on the podcast i was
like i appreciate it but that's
definitely dan wow yeah i'm a guy
it's actually incorrect though because i
am a scorpion and they have exoskeletons
no backbone i'm an invertebrate
try again
sorry abe
nice try i have a question
yeah hit me with the content corn do you
think we call it bontent board
[Music]
[Applause]
big ups for ian killing it on the
switcher says uh tony zappardo for 10
bucks hey thank you big up
ian is not feeling uh particularly well
today so he's oh no what's wrong
i just have a really bad headache today
oh i'm sorry do we have advil did you
you have anything
um
yeah i can take some yeah take some
advil that always helps me a lot i don't
shake it like that it might make his
headache worse yeah maybe maybe just
keep doing that duck
and it's right in his ear a dark ranger
donated five dollars said a b will now
be referred to as ac to keep it fifty
true
ac
what's up ac keep a fitted fifth street
because i'm a [ __ ] yep
that's pretty good
yeah ac keeping it cool
by the way i just had a good idea
because i want to talk to people i'm
actually interested in not these like
[ __ ] celebrities that nobody cares
about who aren't interesting anyway
we should just get a pipeline of andrew
to bring all of his characters he finds
here to the podcast
instead of not all of them but the ones
we like you know i mean like [ __ ] mac
because chris he's doing all the leg
work to find these characters i mean so
it's symbiotic i promote his show
and then i interview him what do you
mean he does all the characters in the
atria universe we could we could maybe
facilitate a trade send him some brad
berries and
right i mean like well i guess we could
see andrew it's not like i'm going to
steal him from him it's like right
oh he might love sea man he would love
seaman yeah exactly he should go to the
foot party well like i got nothing to
offer he should go to the footpath okay
so here you go all of a sudden now i got
something to offer you
well that's what i mean it's like it
needs to be a little bit entertaining
no i i i agree i just feel like you know
we shouldn't
he's just trying to keep it fit i want
to i don't want to be perceived as
taking advantage of our friendship with
andrew you know
take an advantage
yeah
take advantage
he's fine
he's out there doing the leg work
finding all these okay so he finds these
interesting characters and then what
nobody's allowed to talk to them no but
you're saying we should just get
everybody that he is
i'm working with andrew well if you want
to work on the game with her all right i
promote his show it's great how does
that how does that hurt andrew i
it doesn't hurt him i just you know i
just want him to feel
like he's
he's getting something in return
go off king
you want you should go work for andrew
at this point
god
damn keeping it 55th street
yeah i mean he could go he could go to
the foot conference i'd [ __ ] kill to
watch that
man that would be fun
that'd be amazing actually
if he doesn't that one of you guys
should
i was gonna send my brother
one of us should go to the foot
conference that would be the best
segment ever i'll suggest it to andrew
but i don't know if that's his thing but
one of you guys should definitely go
in fact love why don't you come out for
that
no what are you saying
with peas and love
let's wear some thick boots
i'll go somewhere
cover those feet
i'd actually be intrigued yeah me too i
kind of want to go
why it'd probably be safer for a for a
woman to go because it's like men are
there oh i
are
is it a party for all
gay men like i think it's for men it's
foreign oh yeah i would love to go
because like if zack goes they're gonna
be thirsting all over your feet bro
although again we're not these these
people are not like
they're not like
criminals they're not gonna force them
they just let you know they're just like
no no they're not fired in the hip
some of them might be also zach zac's
feet were rated
you know seat here so well i don't know
my brother maybe you know
um cameron said he hated my feet i might
be safe that's true cameron he really he
didn't like any of our feet just to be
fair to you yeah we all just had
creative feet is what he said
in his frodo feet
he'll be good
i think it'd be interesting to follow
him around and then see which foot he
really loves you know
yeah
i bet it was okay that's what kept
saying it's okay
yeah that's what he said about all the
ones he hated he said that about mine
too
he was trying to be respectful though i
appreciate that respectful king
okay so at any rate
got a bunch of calls
oh yeah let's take a couple calls let's
see
there was one that i saw that i thought
oh yeah check out um number 36
jose
36.
jose works in establishment oh
that sounds good yeah
okay jose
okay jose i understand you have a call
uh interesting story for us
yeah uh so first of all i just want to
say it's a
honor and a privilege to be on well
thank you very much i'm happy to have
you on here as well
thank you thank you i know by the way
you are the most gangster person
i can think of that's what i thought i
don't know why everyone in here is being
so poo-poo about it
i've just been appalled i just i
couldn't wait to speak up about yeah
okay so yeah apologies jose
i'm sorry nothing go ahead what's your
story
right so um
i work at a certain establishment i
don't really want to say where
uh just because i don't want to i know
what state myself uh
i'm sorry what state
texas okay
okay so um the other day
i wouldn't say that he frequents this
place i don't want to say he does or
doesn't but maybe he does alex jones
so uh
yeah so he walks in he walks in and he
goes uh
our employees ask if he can take a
selfie he goes yeah of course
um and he goes up to me he he looks at
me he goes are you the supervisor you
know that voice of it you're the
supervisor are you a supervisor
supervisor
all right
um so he goes hey uh
you order the great reset
and i go what
and he goes a great reset uh yeah look
it up
i go okay
okay um so i asked one of my managers
about what it was he explained it to me
and i was like holy crap this guy's as
crazy
in real life as he is in freaking
in his show
well what is the great reset
did he explain it to you thing about
oh man i uh he no he didn't explain it
to me he told me to look it up
okay so so i
the great reset
you're not familiar with this i'm pretty
familiar oh no i've never heard of it
it's a it's a conspiracy theory that um
that basically the global the global
elite are planning on resetting society
uh to uh establish a one-world currency
and one world government and uh they're
using code 19 to do it oh so this
this is a good new one
it's like a new one but it's also it's
it's a remix let's be honest it doesn't
make much sense because on one hand they
say kova 19 is not dangerous but then
they're saying kova 19 is going to reset
the world economy how's that going to
make sense well i think they're using
cobia 19 and the restrictions in order
to
gain some level of control
so why did he casually bring that up to
you jose
he did i don't know uh he literally he
just goes after
after they asked me like after they
asked him hey can i get a selfie he goes
up he just bears him and he goes
do you know what the great reset is look
it up
that could be part of his stick too you
know what i mean hey look at hey hey how
you doing look up the great scene reset
all right nice to see you
it seems like [ __ ]
i got it he's like he usually he's like
calm when he answers but uh
i don't know i didn't expect him to
actually have that uh keep the stick up
you know like in real life
but it's like you know i i i get it it's
good he's he's giving the people what he
wants it's like hey the great reset nice
to see you
you know
he was popular as hell over here
everyone was taking photos everyone
loved me like an icon here so but he's
got a good reputation at the restaurant
people like um
yeah no people he comes in frequently
well then like oh good question does he
tip does he tip i'm sorry does alex
jones tip well
uh well we'd our certain establishment
is kind of weird with tips
uh so that certain terminal he was at
did not take tips that's why he goes
there he's a terrible tipper
i'm calling it exactly he told me i come
here specifically to not give you tips
he laughed at my face yeah that's
interesting why don't you lead with that
all right jose well they don't want to
damage his perfect reputation
yeah of course
well uh all right jose well next time
you see him tell him that the uh sandy
hook parents send their regard
my god my god no i i swear to god one of
one of our uh managers was like i didn't
know who he was looked him up on google
she was terrified how the [ __ ] do you
not know who alex jones is that's crazy
to me i don't know i honestly i have no
idea but she looked them up and she was
like honestly she was like why did we
let him in here that's right that's the
right reaction
that's true he's totally well okay
thanks for sharing good luck out there
okay buddy thanks then stay safe out
there thank you thanks for taking my
call are you offended by my texas jokes
by the way
i love your texas i'm not originally
from i moved here recently so uh fair
enough i i i take it with uh
great okay you know
i'm glad to hear it well i do i do it in
good humor because we we love our texans
we love our texans so thank you jose
thanks jose
shout out to texas
[Applause]
come on down to texas now boys
they putting vaccine in the water
[Music]
i should clarify by the way because i'm
i'm sure people will get upset at me but
the the great reset it like is an actual
thing
but alex jones and his ilk have a lot of
conspiracy theories about it so it's not
something real thing uh
apparently it's
some program that the world economic uh
forum was advocating for last year okay
so it's it's they had a conference
called the great reset okay so as all
good conspiracy theories there's a
nugget of truth from a nugget of truth
yes exactly
they're like we should have a call where
we can finally get some kind of
standardization on how to
handle a pandemic and then alex jones
like they killing us all
right there's the great reset
right
but yeah so it's not any ding-dongs it's
not made
up uh whole cloth uh out of
uh nothing but
yeah
all right let's talk to sh uh
shay
yes you have a story you wanna share
with us it sounds kind of interesting
let's hear it
yeah i do so um this was back when i was
in college um and i was part of this big
friend group
um and one of them so we all knew each
other just because we were taking
classes together so we weren't that
close
but we did you know have lunch together
and interact a lot so there was this one
guy that was part of it that like we
really didn't interact one-on-one a
whole lot but
we all went to
lunch one day and everybody bailed like
nobody else could make it they just had
other engagements and it was our usual
time so um
it ended up being just me and him so we
had lunch it was like 2 p.m it was in
the afternoon
and um and he um he was you know we sat
together
and then he like followed me back to my
dorm um which like i knew him it was
fine we were gonna hang out um and he
was like
you know like yeah let's hang out um so
hold on hold on one sec here so you guys
had dinner together you guys or what or
lunch you guys had a meal together
and then went back to your door dining
hall
okay okay i had a brunch in a dining
hall yeah so
and then went back to your right so
exactly yeah he just followed like he
followed me there he was like oh well i
got nothing going on okay so you didn't
invite him
he was just like okay well let's go hang
out at your dorm and you you you didn't
basically want to say no you were too
uncomfortable to say no what happened
well it was it was you know it was 2 p.m
it was on campus he was part of my
friend group you know i was like all
right let's hang out it's not that i was
uncomfortable why not you know i just um
i didn't invite him exactly he just was
why not exactly so
i you know we were sitting on my bed and
my roommate was there too so we were i
was showing him like my youtube videos
like um you know some old like you know
early 2018 stuff
um and um and he was sitting like really
close to me on my bed
yeah i was probably showing him vape
niche you know
um
and um my roommate left for her class so
so like like reminder it was 2pm
and my roommate had just left for her
like 45 minute class and so he was so
eventually like we were just hanging out
on the on my bed and i was i'm kind of
oblivious just in general and also he
was never very nice to me like he was
just some like guy that was part of our
friend group he was never very friendly
he was just like kind of there you go
you know so how were you guys seated on
the bed what were you doing on the bed i
understand there's not enough not a lot
of space
exactly so we're both like
legs like like side by side legs like
outward doing what
outward
just like sitting so like i had my
laptop on my table so i was like hey
like check out these funny videos like
he's a bud you know okay um
and and so like he scoots like closer
and closer after my after my roommate
leaves and again i'm like i'm dumb and
oblivious like and also i don't have
those feelings so i never even thought
about it yeah he probably he was like
eventually he said yeah
yeah i can see he's he sees this as his
opening here
he thinks
and probably he even thinks you're
inviting him
which obviously isn't true
you know but sure like yeah you know
it's like it's it is what it is it was
also towards the end of the year so like
we're all super stressed out about
finals
and so so we're watching video he he
touches his leg to mind and then he goes
so do you want to like fool around wow
and i'm so dead
well dude i was like i thought that's
what we are doing like we're just like
you know fooling around on my computer
like dude
um
i didn't pick up on it at all
but so so that's what i said i was like
we i that's what we are doing and he
like
like he just like saw he said he said
never mind
and then he left immediately after and
then as soon as he left i was like oh
he's
he's trying to get down
um
he used the wrong language he should
have said do you want to get down not
fool around
[Music]
that's interesting so let me just let me
just if he wanted if he wanted me to
have sex with him he should have been
kind to me like that's kind of the thing
right like yeah that's a good start
that's a good thing well okay let me ask
you this if he was nice to you would you
have had sex with them
no um it was finals i was so stressed
out and again it was 2pm
and it was in my dorm my shared dorm
so like the timing was terrible
and the situation was terrible like it
was all just bad
okay so what happened
yeah so like it's fine like it just you
know it was normal i didn't think
anything of it and so the school year
ended and i went back home and he went
like everybody went back home um you
know to our different states and um but
he hadn't like we all you know we were
friends we were all friends on facebook
we all had that information about each
other so like um maybe like a couple of
months into me going back to my job i
worked i worked at customer service and
so my manager brings me into her back
office and she was like we got a call
from somebody saying that they had a big
problem with your attitude
um and and i have been working there for
about six years no complaints ever um
and she and that's why she approached me
like this is super weird somebody's
calling about you complaining about you
she said it was weird because he
referred to you by your nickname
instead of the name on your
uh on your name tag so if it was a
regular customer he would have called me
by my name bag right he was clearly
somebody that knew me but that kind of
didn't really i hadn't put the dots
together at that point but he
self-reported maybe a week later he
messaged me on facebook and was like so
did your manager have a talk with you
what the [ __ ] what a creepy freaking
weirdo
so weird and gross what an insult
i mean yeah the whole it was crazy the
whole encounter gives me in-cell vibes
because
like the way he goes in there and then
he creates like a normal situation
with no build up no conversation of just
like hey so you want to have sex and
then bails when you say no right the
whole thing is in cell energy but
calling and complaining at your work is
super freaky what did you say to him
yeah
i did i blocked him immediately and i
told my manager i was like hey so this
is kind of the situation and like if
that ever happens again i want you to
know that like
it's because of this like i she was
immediately not believing it because you
know he sounded young like we were you
know 25
um and um
and and because of that name tag thing
you know he referred to be my by my
nickname so
did you tell the rest of your friends i
was just done
oh i told everybody oh yeah i was like
guess what the freaking guy did was
there any fallout in the friend group
well for sure yeah like it was we were
all essentially just friends of
convenience we all were taking classes
together so we all hung out so that was
sort of the dynamic so it wasn't a big
deal there wasn't like a oh taking sides
thing it was just like well now we're
not in the classes anymore so there's
not really any reason for me to interact
with you anyway and you're a creep oh
okay so bye all right well
shay says she was harassed by an incel
we don't love that
thank you for sharing your story shay
peace and love thank you so much
congratulations on your beautiful family
i love you guys so much oh my gosh thank
you congratulations on um
having holding a job for six years and
being in college it sounds like you got
all all kinds of things going in your
favor
all right
thank you so much well have a great
thank you so much you know
it ain't easy being a woman i'll say
that man sure you've got some fun i mean
there's pros and cons obviously right
but that's one thing that sucks dude is
you've got like weird insoles they just
expect you to have sex with them and
then harass you when you don't
it's not easy it's not easy it's not
easy being an insult
it's not
what are we going to do without insults
they take the red pill
they realize that women they just want
to have sex with strangers
not jordan peterson i went there i
believe i can't believe this set this
off this is actually a take i've heard
jordan say women just want to have sex
with
rich successful men
and if you're not successful what do we
do about those men we need equity we
need to make sure that women are having
sex with ugly unsuccessful men too men
they're doing impossible things wait did
you say that jordan peterson suggested
that at one point he had a whole weird
take about
you could probably find on the internet
about how a small amount of men are
successful sexually and it's causing
problems for unsuccessful men
which is weird because he's talking
about inequality of outcome which is
what he's always preaching again that's
called it's that is literally cultural
marxism yeah
he he he has cultural marxism
that's unbelievable to find it yeah what
are we gonna do without
men that is more cultural marxism which
by the way is not a thing but that is
more
cultural marxism than anything he has
ever taught no it's the weirdest
takeaway that is incredible it's one of
the first things i saw where i was like
this is just weird jordan
try to find it because it's really good
ugly men need [ __ ] too
what are we gonna do without
when ugly men don't get [ __ ]
and these women
these stuck at women
they only want to [ __ ] successful guys
that don't creep them out what kind of
[ __ ] is that
if i was a woman i'd [ __ ] an ugly guy
once a month
just just to bring order to society
somebody in chat said he wants to
socialize [ __ ]
exactly
a hundred percent
you gotta find that clip bro i'm telling
you the truth i i i like vaguely
remember this um
unsuccessful men what are we gonna do
if ugly men can't get laid they shoot up
mosques
what are we gonna do
i think this is it again yes so many
videos without he's not in this but he
could hear his voice he's voicing the
chaos of the casual encounter
the chaos
what are we gonna do about the chaos of
[ __ ]
if men are getting laid
i'm telling you movie theaters are going
to get blacks blown up
i would say
very i don't know that this is it this
seems like really dramatic
i think it is though give it if you're
just looking like the first 30 seconds
okay let's give it a shot
the chaos
i'll i'll say this
if you're an attractive woman you owe it
to an ugly guy to [ __ ] him
roll it it's not right to keep that
[ __ ] for all the to all the non-creepy
dudes uh
it's not right men are doing impossible
things
and then they don't get laid on top of
it
that's where you get black filled
because of women
a [ __ ] i hate women
they keep all the good [ __ ] to
themselves
and then you've got men like hassan he's
tall and jacked he gets all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] him
and [ __ ] women too
i deserve [ __ ]
i'm smart as hell
and now i'm rich and i still can't get
laid
what kind of [ __ ] is that
women say i'm creepy [ __ ] you [ __ ]
i'm cool as hell
where would we be without men
you [ __ ] owe me you ought to suck my
dick lady
forthrightly
if i had two men and
all other things being equal one was
capable of serial sexual
relationships and was attractive enough
to manage that and the other wasn't that
the person who
managed to do that okay
watch this any further can we just
reflect on the fact that somebody's
trying to make an inspirational [ __ ]
message out of this with stock photos
and
this is just this is a weird truly
[ __ ] bizarre world we live in but
okay i gotta listen to this from this i
would say i would say very forthrightly
if i had two women
all other things
but i found
i found the choice
quote okay hold on let me let me just
finish this okay we've tried like three
times
let's just try this i got this i got the
ones though okay believe that
so if you're abstinent because you're
incapable that is not a virtue
but
you can't divorce something as
miraculous
as sexuality from your life
how are you gonna do that well you can
trivialize it look at this [ __ ]
virgin the whole world's passing them by
you can't even get [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] little dude
this is what it's like to be a virgin
guys
it's nothing it's so [ __ ] amazing
yeah dudes are pathetic weirdos
this is just sad
miraculous
as sexuality from your life
how are you gonna do this is miraculous
look at this [ __ ]
he's not he can't even get laid look how
sad this [ __ ] is but you can trivialize
it
it's nothing well okay well then then
then you have nothing so
good luck with that you're going to take
one of these sources of meaning that's
available to you and turn it into
nothing well
well
that's its own punishment
well so then you integrate it into your
life well what do you want for your life
do you i mean
do you want to be
what what is what is it that you want
from sex do you want intimacy do you
want closeness
do you even want the experience to be of
high quality do you want the person to
pay attention to you
well they're going to have to care for
you bro i don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on
making sense i stopped listening so long
ago i was like looking to see if this
was like edited because it's just
[ __ ] words
any sense it's just one long run on i
don't know how people will actually
watch this and think it's interesting
but go ahead read the quote
okay new york times interview with the
new york times
uh
can you do it in a jordan peterson
impression no damn i can't i can't
really do it
uh
try it buckle
try it
okay uh
i'm just trying to find the best some uh
some believe in forced sexual
redistribution in which a governing body
would intervene in women's lives to
force them into sexual relationships
violent attacks are what happen when men
don't have partners mr peterson says and
society needs to work to make sure those
men are married he was angry at god
because women were rejecting him mr
peterson says of the toronto killer the
cure for that is enforced monogamy
that's actually why monogamy emerges mr
peterson does not pause when he says
this enforced monogamy is to him simply
a rational solution otherwise women will
all only go for most high status men he
explains and that
couldn't make either gender happy in the
end half the men fail he says meaning
that they don't procreate and no one
cares about the men who fail i laugh
because it's absurd this is the the
author saying that you're laughing about
them he says giving me a disappointed
look
that's because you're female
oh my god this guy yeah no you someone
asked me do i support jordan peterson no
this is dude he talks about this is the
most psychotic [ __ ]
anyone serious has said publicly he is
in favor of forced monogamy because
women are just getting way too much good
dick and we need to equal it for
pathetic dudes who also deserve some
[ __ ] because if they don't get [ __ ]
they're gonna kill people they blow up a
mosque right yeah
sorry
sorry to all of the men in the world
that's our badge
you're laughing about them he gives me a
disappointed look that's because you're
female
wow
because you're one of those female
[ __ ]
and here
the author actually points out what we
were just talking about but aside from
intervention interventions that would
redistribute sex mr peterson is
staunchly against what he calls equality
of outcomes where efforts to make uh
efforts to equalize society he calls
them pathological and evil he agrees
that this is inconsistent but preventing
hordes of single men from violence he
believes is necessary for the stability
of society enforced monogamy helps
neutralize that forced monogamy
who has this is like straight isis [ __ ]
this is like as extreme as like isis do
you understand how psychotic forced
monogamy is i love how his whole theory
on the
his whole theory on the uh let's say
the equality of outcome is like [ __ ]
um
affirmative action is [ __ ] cultural
marxism it's evil
how dare we ensure that black people who
have spent their whole existence in the
ex in this country slavery impoverished
without opportunity
it's [ __ ] evil we have to get rid of
affirmative action
but we need equality of [ __ ]
i i want a affirmative action for [ __ ]
only
[ __ ] poverty
i'm just interested in men getting laid
who suck
i'm advocating for low value men
and then when they have to when they get
[ __ ] she has to marry him
it's forced monogamy
she has to stay with him
because he's a piece of [ __ ] and she'll
leave him for someone better
we can't allow that
[Music]
dude
forced monogamy that's literally like
the hands made sale that's straight
[ __ ] like
christian
theocratic
domestic fascism i don't know what to
say it's also just an abusive
relationship yeah and it's straight up
like domestic abuse yeah an r word and
just horrible
you can't leave your marriage [ __ ] i
bet you want to
my wife tried to leave me i told her
this is forced
monogamy
you knew what you're getting yourself
into
now play down daddy peterson needs to
get his
oh boy
does anybody know what uh
what religion he is is he catholic oh
he's he's very religious
or well christian catholic what's the
[ __ ] difference i don't even know
anything well there's a big difference
but catholicism he's into catholicism in
christianity is he catholic well oh yeah
i don't think he is catholic actually
foreign
[Music]
that's probably i don't think people
know that but that's like so psychotic
that take is beyond [ __ ] insane
holy [ __ ] dude
oh my god it showed me what religion is
jordan
like the country and it said the country
and it said muslim and i was like wait
i'm a [ __ ] muslim
that's a
brother
um i'm saying he's catholic somebody's
saying he is atheist i don't think oh no
he's very nice i've just seen a video
crying about jesus christ he's not
atheist what are you talking about he's
everything he does he's not religious
he's def he talks about no everything he
does is informed by religion and it's
[ __ ] up and weird
i see a quote that says jordan peterson
is a catholic he just hasn't quite
accepted it well he always well that's
not
yeah when people always ask him about
god he goes you're trying to put me in a
box buster
well what do you mean by god general
non-denominational christians
he said i've thought i suppose it's a
form of comedy that catholicism is as
sane as people get it's gothic it's dark
it has the same aesthetic in some sense
as a horror film
very cool jordan thank you
maybe
or maybe what
well anyway can you not find the video
it goes the other way around dude oh my
god
that's [ __ ] dude
i swear i've seen that like vocalized
but anyway i'm glad you found the quote
because yeah that's that's ape [ __ ]
right there buddy
why do people keep saying benzoic oh
[ __ ] i get it
i'm benzoist
he's a custer
i didn't get [ __ ] for so long i got
addicted to benzos
with michaela
wait what was that
look it up
he's got that southern bap
baptisy energy
yeah a little bit
people are saying he's a custer catholic
certified custer
custocy
[Laughter]
force monogoosie
oh boy
yo forced monogamy
that's the wildest [ __ ] man
all right well let's move it on if you
guys find that clip i'll pull it up but
otherwise let's let's get to the the um
yeah
this is like the third thing on our dock
that's the fun of hdtv we just keep it
55th street
i'm a [ __ ] queen
all right so um listen the quartering is
always tweeting out like absolute dog
[ __ ]
and i guess somehow the quartering and
keemstar i feel like they should be
aligned but
somehow they are beefing
abe revealed to me today that this beef
actually has some history it goes back a
while yeah they were even in 2018 over
some [ __ ]
but um there's [ __ ] all over the floor
yeah they they whine about all the same
things essentially so it is kind of
surprising that they're not
energetically aligned
it's interesting because i kind of
forced to pick a side in a way
and i have to say i mean
well let's let's go nobody's forcing you
to pick a side to be fair i was actually
really curious
okay so let's let's let's go over it and
then we can decide who's the bigger
douche here okay okay so demand uh the
quartering with his insane takes as
usual and of course the more insane
right wing psycho [ __ ] you tweet the
more likes it gets i've noticed that
with like matt walsh
you know
his base bro exactly he's a baseball
only racist and just ignorant you are
the more based you are
so when you and your family tune into
disney plus to watch the mandalorian
remember that the main actor pedro
pascal is mourning the death of a man
that you know uh r worded i'm i'm just
i'm keeping it 55th here
uh
a word a ray ard a child a literal p
word a violent p word he did so publicly
yes so of course the
quartering's talking about kind of kyle
rittenhouse thing one of the people kyle
killed
was a convicted p word of course kyle
didn't know that about him when he shot
him like that that isn't justif it's
just
okay and then i don't think uh pedro was
literally just what did pedro actually
say he was probably just is this tweet
i'll show you right now yeah let's get
the context here
joseph ross inbound third
well okay i mean
that's an interesting thing i wouldn't
say a rest in peace
that's kind of i feel like actually
what do you think about this tweet
uh i mean i wouldn't wish a rest in
peace to a convicted p word they
probably didn't know that about him at
the time yeah probably not
also i think
i i suspect remember that uh the
quartering has this very unhealthy
obsession with gina carano or whatever
her name is who obviously was on the
show but okay pedro pascal so there's
some by the way one of the guys murdered
was like
a good dude a medic who was like
do i have that right one other guy or i
don't remember who you know one of them
was a great dude one of them was a p
word clearly kyle didn't know which is
which
but anyway i get the point
uh whatever he's not being like yo
love these p words
otherwise he'd be in the catholic church
if he loved p words so much
by the way speaking of p words can you
pull that picture that newly serviced
picture of the pope blessing epstein
takes one to no one you were right about
one of the guys being a medic by the way
yeah so one was a terrible dude one was
a great dude it doesn't matter what kind
of dude they were kyle kyle shot and
killed them you know what i mean
i mean
basically irrefutable evidence
yeah by the way this picture recently
surfaced which is pretty awesome
i was like damn dude um
i was like oh [ __ ] probably not the
first p word the pope's met
in fact he probably surrounded by them
all day in fact he might even be one
himself i don't [ __ ] care
you know what i mean
i mean [ __ ] just you just keep me at
55th street i'm just giving it a 50 fish
sure you know what i'm saying i would
never trust my kid in the damn
i don't know how to do it other than
that one thing
but you gotta love that eh
when was this photographed was it before
2003 was that after his first no
okay
you've got to assume the people the poop
pope meets they vet them a little bit
though so you're not blessing people
like him
because once the pope blesses god's like
i can't what can i do
he's in heaven now
do you think in heaven like when someone
like
because eps let's say the way that
christianity works you accept jesus you
go to heaven no questions asked right
right
i think there's a little more to it but
no i don't that's what it's all about
you accept jesus into your heart you
repent you go to heaven bob's your uncle
that's all i mean is anyone here know
about that stuff i mean a little bit on
my mom's side my grandfather was a
preacher i'm pretty sure that's how it
works
my question is go ahead i was raised
catholic so i like got my communion when
i was a kid but it's just say
it's like
yeah it's essentially i mean chat you
can correct me if i'm wrong here but the
point i'm driving at is that basically
no i don't do you think
when someone like you know one of these
priests
one of these p word priests
goes to heaven that there's just like
tons of kids for him
oh i
hate that idea it's heaven right oh my
god that's his idea of heaven
just saying the pope's there hanging out
with epstein i think that's the bath
like birch
that's the bath thing
yeah that's the bath like church boy i'm
just saying yeah people are saying i'm
right so i'm saying go to heaven
they got their own version of 55 virgins
you know what i'm saying
what's that you're looking at me no i'm
just looking over
uh the chat's saying you're wrong third
some said ethan is right some say i'm
wrong
yeah it's disgusting i know i'm just
talking about that they're all a bunch
of p words [ __ ] them
[ __ ] all the people in this picture
i hate it it's disgusting moving on
speaking of disgusting the quartering
[Laughter]
peanut pita
anyway
uh oh people are just getting to the
part where i said that joke so i'm just
reading the response
it's not my idea of heaven by the way
either someone said ethan has a point
just saying
just saying
i want to see you interview wendy
williams now that would be interesting
i'd love to i mean you know
just saying i haven't seen the
azalea banks uh
like layups on wendy williams have you
seen those no oh my god hold on
someone said here there's some people
arguing with me they're saying
if heaven is even real then i would
imagine it would take away the desire
and urge to harm anyone okay so that's
fair i i like that idea
well they wouldn't be like real people
it would just be like your idea of
heaven is meant as a perfect and pure
paradise no p word allowed okay fair
enough who paradise for who then
you wanna
you wanna see something really
interesting always
when the pope
comes to new york city
he stays at the archdiocese uh like
house manor thing in manhattan yeah
that's a good ass location yeah it sure
is what the pope stays on 72 and like at
central park east that's like he's
chilling bro you know what this house is
let me guess jeffrey epstein's mansion
holy [ __ ] they could literally walk into
each other's backyard they literally can
because they share a back area
that's [ __ ] interesting right there
dude
that's [ __ ] interesting
just saying just saying yo that's such
an expensive place to live i've seen
owned a whole building there
that's crazy like a famous house is
herbert and strauss house
yeah well it's a historic landmark
it's bad juju there now
she got a little discount for that
i'm gonna keep it 72 street i used to
actually live on 72th street when me and
a little bit there on the west side
or 73rd street actually sorry
i would distance myself from that street
if i were you well it's a big street i
mean you can't i mean
there's no such thing
73 i was on 73 okay well then you're
good yeah just saying
just saying
okay anyway so the quartering says when
you and your family tune into disney
plus
to watch the mandalorian remember that
the main actor pedro pascal is mourning
the death of a man that a word a r
worded a child a literal p word a
violent p world p word he did so
publicly okay so it's a little
misleading he he he was saying rest in
peace to both of the people that kyle
killed
it's not like he went out of his way to
acknowledge he he probably didn't know
about this guys
you know history
and then keemstar comes on top which is
real interesting that keemstar put his
neck out
on this specific take too right
he says this guy claims to be fighting
sjws and cancel culture but he acts like
just one of the people he's fighting
clown emoji that's actually such a base
take by keemstar
especially considering
it also
100 applies to keemstar totally
i mean
well so keemstar definitely
cancels people
regularly on a show
but i do think
i do think what he's saying about the
quartering is is actually i've long said
quartering is the biggest snowflake on
the earth because quartering
particularly on a regular basis calls
for boycotts canceling calling out
people for being libtards and stuff like
he is literally a sjw snowflake on the
right he is the antithesis
of a snowflake in that he is basically
just a conservative snowflake i'm deep
undercover um so i think keemstar is
right on point obviously there's irony
in it
but yeah keem is super magga so i just
find it interesting that he's putting
his neck out on this particular point
don't you
well he's just saying
you know that the quartering is a whiny
[ __ ] essentially which he's right
yeah he's whining about everything all
the time the quartering comes back
didn't figure came for being pro p word
again it's like dude use your
use your
p brain to actually address the the
conversation he's not saying he's pro p
word he's saying you're a hypocrite
so why do you have to turn that into him
being pro p word like you can't actually
defend your
position also why wouldn't you figure it
came from being pro-p considering his
dating habits right
this is coming from the weirdo who's
upset about she-ra and lola bunny not
having big boobs
he is the king of cancer culture he
literally [ __ ] and tries to get [ __ ]
canceled for the dumbest sjw [ __ ] he's
just he is an sjw he's just a
conservative sjw
dude i'm [ __ ] myself
he's a cultural social he's a cultural
social justice warrior
you know he's a custer
s cjw
yeah so didn't figure keem his pro p
word you know like literally keem didn't
say anything about p word he's just
calling you a [ __ ]
so again
i like you jeremy but this tweet ain't
it dog oh tipster uh oh
oh no the usual suspects are all
converging on this
hey maybe one day keem will let you make
a video on this channel i get it also a
good point and funny
so that's a w for quarter
because basically these guys all suck on
keemstar's titties trying to hopefully
get promoted by him
that's a really good point for jeremy w
ten points for gryffindor yep and then
oh god there's all these [ __ ] this is
awesome dude
i pile on i love watching from the side
man
what part of the quartering statement
are you disagreeing with oh see now we
got the [ __ ] this other cultural
warrior
viva fray
who i'm sure is going to be clipping
this and [ __ ] doing this there's
gonna be a lot of videos like get it
come out of these five minutes yeah
exactly enjoy it ethan is pro p word
breaking
see some crazy thumbnails and [ __ ]
titles after this five minutes tipster
eat
breaking ethan says that i'm in a sexual
relationship with keemstar slander
dom
by the way let me just make clear i am
not pro p word in fact i'm not a pro
anything i'm just narrating this so
before you [ __ ] try to spit well
they're whatever they don't care what
they say you're just the referee yeah
i'm just the referee guys
i'm just enjoying exactly i'm just
enjoying the show
okay but okay so viva frey uh he he
he's just one he's just trying to
clarify what part of the quartering
statement do you disagree with
the statement being
uh that um
pascal
is supporting p word which is
not it's absolutely not
what's happening here uh dude
i mean and according response i mean i
don't mourn the death of violent p words
i guess that's weird to him
i never called for the guy to be fired
just pointing out facts oh really bro
he goes i did not ask anyone to fire him
i'm just saying when you tune into his
show on disney plus
to remember what a piece of [ __ ] he is
and that you support that piece of [ __ ]
and this show
you guys are you guys so [ __ ]
cowardly that you can't even own up to
what you're doing like if you're gonna
do this game or pretend like i'm not
doing that i'm not just stop being
cowards and at least own what you're
doing
you know go watch someone else
i've already chose that i mean
i don't mourn the death of violent p
words
just [ __ ] own it bro i never called
for the guy to be fired just pointed out
a fact such a coward
gina isn't gonna [ __ ] you dude yeah
exactly she gina is never gonna [ __ ] you
bro no matter how many times you
talk about how great her feet look
or photoshop yourself together with her
i'm stepdad hugs you give her it's just
not going to happen bro oh my god a
little came out
i know okay so
oh is this a video or because then yes
how do i watch it it's it's in the dock
right below yeah so then keemstar made
one of his classic um
twitter videos
this is so good isn't it i really have
started to enjoy uh
the the keem rant on twitter video
genre he's really like
stepped it up recently like he he does
these all the time and it's always gold
i mean he's been doing him for a while
he's he definitely has a talent
steady hands
didn't figure keem for being a p word so
pro p word so here's the quartering aka
jeremy you and your fans have lost your
goddamn mind forever you've been saying
you're against cancer culture and you're
against the social justice warriors
you're against going after sponsors and
all this other [ __ ] right well
apparently some actor made a claim rest
in peace to the [ __ ] pedophile that
kyle rittenhouse killed in self-defense
all right so you got upset about that
and you want to call the guy out but
instead of calling the actor out you
decide to put out a tweet saying oh when
your family is watching disney plus and
they're watching the star wars series be
reminded that the lead actor is a
[ __ ] pedophile supporter or whatever
why did you add disney plus why did you
[ __ ] add that he's in her star wars
series why didn't you just talk about
the actor because you're being a social
justice cancel culture warrior [ __ ]
hypocrite that's why so i call you out
for that and your fans then respond oh i
guess you support pedophiles you know
who else acts this way the cancel
culture [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] all over
the [ __ ] internet your fans are just
like that now you
respond you jeremy yourself respond and
say i didn't think keemstar would be pro
pedophile but i guess he is you are a
social justice warrior cancel culture
[ __ ] [ __ ] just like everyone else on
this goddamn site you are no different
than the people
out look at your actions look at your
tweets look how you [ __ ] act look how
your [ __ ] mindless sheep fans act
look what they say look how they spin
narratives you're all a complete joke
and only keemstar lives in base
reality thank you
okay so
the quartering oh what the f is this
real yeah
this is his assistant wait i never saw
this photo when was this posted
it was a while ago i think you saw we
showed it on the show yeah bro that
looks like a father-daughter day like
legitimately
she's still got her braces on and [ __ ]
also look how look how flat his dome is
like because the bandana is so tight you
can see there's not a single bump on
that dome
that is smooth
i [ __ ] up
anyway
rare w for keemstar because
as much as a hypocrite as he is because
he is always canceling people on the
show i do think he's right and that the
quartering is the biggest social justice
warrior of all time yeah he's totally
right it's just it's ironic coming from
keemstar but keemstar doesn't engage in
it in the same way the quartering does
and that the quartering is regularly
calling out sponsors calling out shows
boycotting canceling people like he is
actually a social justice warrior
keemstar like cancels people on the show
but what the quartering does is like
legit textbook sjw [ __ ]
so w for keemstar in that regard
um
here we go it continues this is awesome
keem doesn't understand cancel culture
at all yeah it's not it's not casual
culture when i do it it's only cancer
culture when lefties do it
and it's just salty he got ratio trying
to defend pedro let's mourn a child r
word pasco
bro
what does he not understand about cancel
culture
you know
genuinely curious
uh two [ __ ] on different teams
another video yeah so that's also in the
doug awesome
let's go
did you just say i'm ratio of you you're
just mad because i ratioed you
you know who else ray shows me
everything's on [ __ ]
why oh
you got to cry about hassan ray showing
you
what a baby it's true let's keem don't
pretend like getting ratio doesn't hurt
like
you did get ratioed
really hard
by the quartering which is pretty i mean
it just feels bad in sad yeah
you get ratio to hassan
that's one thing but they get rationed
by the quartering that's just
embarrassing definitely definitely huh
yeah you and hassan [ __ ]
completely different [ __ ] spectrums
of the political landscape ratio and
keemstar
i don't know
one
nobody [ __ ] likes me i've accepted it
but two
you kind of cheated in all of this you
and hassan pike are both of you because
your political [ __ ] hacks which means
you come out oh he he's he's got this
whole rationale about why people are
able to ratio him to make him sleep
better yeah
you got ratio because you've yeah nobody
likes you probably and also you have bad
takes this one you're actually right on
but nobody likes you so you say i
[ __ ] love trump or i love aoc or
whatever the [ __ ] and you automatically
get support because people are on the
same [ __ ] team you have bad takes
like hassan [ __ ] coming out saying uh
yeah i love socialism i love bernie
sanders but then he buys a two million
dollar [ __ ] mansion or some [ __ ]
right so dumb bro i can't believe you're
parroting that dumb [ __ ]
well i can't
but that's what that's what's so
interesting because keemstar is manga he
eats the onion all the time and the
quartering would say the same thing
about hassan which is totally dunk
complete misunderstanding of socialism i
mean i don't doubt that
uh keem is you know ten's right wing
no he's magga i don't know if he's full
blown man he is he's mega he's like a
vocal supporter of trump every time on
twitter constantly and like in that
video he he said kyle rittenhouse like
murdered people
based on self-defense and like he's
clearly
no i agree
on the whole i don't know there's just
been some times okay he's mega yeah he
he's a vocal trump supporter gotcha
yeah he doesn't give any of his [ __ ]
money to the people
giant hypocrite he doesn't get called
out because
he's on a team so he gets team support
you're on a team too bro
ben shapiro
like a whole [ __ ] segment about it i
mean
dude stop
calling out dizzy plus you're calling
out the [ __ ] star wars series you're
literally trying to get this [ __ ]
actor fired right huge hypocrite
quartering but you know what you ratio
me you want to know why because you're
on a [ __ ] team
i'm on this guy's team support me but
guys
no one gives a [ __ ] about your ratio
this is man [ __ ] between me and you
you're [ __ ] wrong i'm going to see ty
lopez is in his garage gonna show off
his car garage
i'll tell you what i got [ __ ] cool
cars you can't ratio me and i know it
and you know it you [ __ ] ugly little
[ __ ] i got [ __ ] slapped by a man in
a [ __ ] dress it got so salty your
pathetic ass went to youtube and raised
money to sue the guy in a dress that
punched you that's some [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] forever
well that might be true you also wrote
an email to susan trying to get my
channel banned so
you guys are an equal footing as far as
bit [ __ ] goes
um
yes i was violently assaulted by a
leftist antifa guy the quartering
response well my back was turned because
he was a real tough guy are you
pro-assault now too
maybe look up how it ended for him wait
what is this hint is badly what is this
about you know this story this is he got
jumped at at gen con by something
at a convention i think we talked about
it we talked about the content yeah oh i
didn't know a dude in was he wearing a
dress
i never knew that i never knew that
detail okay so somebody jumped the
quartering at what con gen con it's like
a game developer is that where he got
banned for life yes i think he
eventually got
unbanned maybe
i mean he was the one that was assaulted
like he didn't start the fight but then
they ended up just banning him and the
other guy yeah a point of order he was
not wearing a dress check the police
record he also taught self-defense
ironically okay point of order i was
attacked
but he was not wearing a dresser on her
where did keem even get that from i you
know keane he just makes sense
yeah he's wearing a dress
okay this is pretty interesting so
um
what do you so this is the whole uh take
is there more here let's see
yeah
you checked this morning maybe there
wasn't any uh yeah no update i think
that's the they both ran out of steam
after that but yeah in the case of
quartering versus keem i mean it's hard
to say there's there's some dubbies and
some l's
i mean clearly i i agree with the
keemstar's thesis that the quartering is
just a giant sjw
you know the courtroom's original take
is
i have to actually say though if i'm
being fair a little weird of pedro to
whisk russian rest in peace to a violent
p-word he probably didn't know though
yeah the other guy he wished rest in
peace was a good guy
well they
right-wingers all say that he wasn't
either because he had he also had a
record of like
domestic violence or something
okay so and and and the consensus
amongst the conservatives is that if
people have done bad things
you you could be killing them dead
you're going to be cut down i think
that's kind of the wider point
anyone is that could be murdered
kyle did not know any of these things
when he shot them and b
it's not
really a reason to it's such a weird
take he's like a murderer or somebody so
by the way i've been i've been trying to
i've been trying to uh formulate my
opinion on the whole
kyle rittenhouse thing
lots of ends lots i'll get to that
afterwards i want to talk about it
written house
they should do a cory in the house
version of with kyle written in the
house
and there's just always protesters
outside and he's like
just firing at him
kyle written in the house
you have to protect the k-mart
at 2am right
yeah i saw like such a creep
i said kyle if you go there just don't
go in his basement
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
so anyway um
did you see though that um
uh
the kyle rittenhouse did an interview
with tucker uh last night and he said he
supports uh black lives matter and
immediately all of the people that were
uh supporting him wait for real oh yeah
super interesting this is actually
really [ __ ] actually showed that to
me well so it came out that like tucker
was doing a whole docu series about him
yeah nobody knew about so cut so he wow
that's really brave i actually have to
say that's really brave of him to say
that well he's trying to rehabilitate
his
image all the people supporting him
are gonna be totally pissed off by that
i mean he has nothing to gain by saying
that and everything to lose doesn't he
um i mean
true i guess by the way um keemstar in
case you guys want to save this one
nobody likes me keemstar 2021 with a
tear
murder animals
did you send the clip or i just see
monogamy what is this oh that's i think
that's what you're looking for with
jordan peterson
okay well hold on we're all over the
place scatter shot right now
show me that kyle rent house yeah
i do want to watch that monogamy clip by
the way
it's going to take me i found it it's an
instagram link i'm not a racist person i
support the blm movement i support
peacefully demonstrating
and i believe there needs to be change
rittenhouse had been on trial for
shooting three men killing two during
violent protests last summer in kenosha
wisconsin i'm not a racist person that's
interesting
i feel like he only stands to alienate
himself from all of his racist [ __ ]
people that have adopted him as their
poster boy
wait what is this oh so these are all
the psycho white white uh nationalists
who are now being like i don't like him
anymore
not a fan of yeah you see what i'm
saying like
kyle don't do this they're not going to
forgive you they're not going to stop
hating you you're always going to be
their bugaboo nothing you can ever
possibly say can change this what if and
i and i'll post this as a psychotic
hypothetical what if he actually
is just
saying what he thinks
i'm
inclined to believe it's cynical but
you're right that the what is the
structure what does he have to gain from
seeing it yeah i mean show me more
necessarily some
rational actors he's claiming that he's
getting death threats all the time maybe
he's just trying to save his ass almost
like he did
he might be like
morally trying to pay penance
yeah
but look at this black pill because he
said he i feel like i kind of predicted
this but i'm not going to stop
supporting because i don't believe it's
genuine well this guy doesn't believe
he's genuine there you go look he hasn't
missed his profile picture
yeah but
i'm sure like if if if i was him
i would be
i'm not if i was him but like the best
thing to do in his self-interest is to
play up this whole [ __ ] thing
well i think generally he is i mean he's
making a documentary with [ __ ] talk
or carlson no but you can't literally a
white nationalist blm that's like death
sentence these guys are black filled now
yeah their heroes turn to the dark side
literally
i wish i could have got a better view of
tucker's face
when he said that
remember kiddo supports blue lives
matter he said that just to calm the
waters
hey don't don't you [ __ ] invoke larry
david
people
that post stuff like that how can you be
a white supremacist and also use larry
david meme
they probably say like they say about
any race oh he's he's he's a good jew
he's a good he's one of the good ones
yeah he's one of the good ones larry
david's a lib tart i'm sure of it
he's not one of the good ones
no jews are any of the good they don't
have to have the same political views
it's just if they like them then they
make an exception for uh celebs
right artists
so that's interesting but anyway um
larry david is literally uh
well didn't we remember during the
election
somebody did like a dna test and he's
like second cousins with bernie
he's like literally no yeah they can
sound the same no they're literally
related oh no way that's [ __ ] crazy
not that that determines your political
outlook or anything but yes they are
related
no way yeah he played bernie on the snl
yeah it was probably that was the irony
there's so much resemblance between them
love that for them
so anyway in short i think keemstar
takes the dub and the quartering is just
in such an insufferable sjw freak show
that uh
somehow
i know keemstar takes a twist for the
worse here at the end
when he talks about how um
hassan is a socialist hypocrite it's
like dude shut up
like why why did he even invoked hassan
in that conversation just because
they're both political and he thinks and
he got ratio by both of them i guess
yeah the ratio thing kind of took a
twist but on the face value i think
that's a rare w for keem for sure
i mean the cornering only takes l's by
the way and hassan is political but i
would
i would
uh definitely not call him like an sjw
chancellor like he's
not at all the stuff of anything
he's against it but he's not actively
participating in
canceling stuff like the quartering
right
you know
here's another great one
oh here it is yeah this is the show i'm
pitching
this is exactly it kyle in the house
spent three weeks praying for this dude
to be acquitted just for him to say this
i mean really
you are such a freak
you are such a loser
psychotic freak
for him to just casually say i support
protest i support blm and then this is
just i spent three i wasted three weeks
praying
i want my prayer back
what a refund
yeah i want my prayers back
i changed my mind kyle is not white i
repeat not white code brown code brown
he is not one of us oh my god you guys
these people are literally
i mean this
i knew he was going to [ __ ] but i didn't
expect to be this quick and this blatant
you support the people who tried to kill
you in salah they shall succeed next
time what's with that
god willing inshallah yeah
that's what that essentially is after
supporting them for so long this made me
throw up in my mouth
anti-woke one
cool man yeah so you see the forces he's
playing with but anyway my take on the
whole written house thing
if you want it
[Music]
i've been so here's the thing
kyle
it was here's the thing
it's hard to convict someone in those
circumstances it seems like it was self
like arguably self defense
but the part where kyle is guilty
abe said delete me from this
conversation that's fine don't just
don't say anything this is my opinion i
mean
the part where kyle's guilty
is that he went to a protest that had
nothing to do with them
armed
and created an unsafe situation so i
would say while
the people he killed and shot i would
say you know you can legally say was in
self-defense
um and looking over the details and
stuff i i you can credibly argue that
you know he was in fear for his life or
bodily harm that's
but he [ __ ] went there
to a volatile protest okay these people
are protesting an unarmed black man
being killed by the police this is an
extremely volatile protest they're
burning [ __ ] they're riding
he goes there with a gun
what the [ __ ] do you expect to happen
okay you're gonna run into another
protester with a gun
he's going there
expecting to get in a [ __ ] gunfight
or knowing that's a strong possibility
there's no reason for him to be there
there's no need for him to be there the
fact of that being that the only
violence that took place that night was
the people he killed yeah the only
people who died were the two that he
killed exactly so he was preventing
violence then he failed in that mission
that's proof that he was the reason for
that violent situation now what's really
[ __ ] up is that
the person that bum rushed him to begin
with
was someone off his meds who was
mentally unwell
he was protecting himself
actually kyle was running from him
saying fr friendly friendly friendly
trying to get the guy to chill saying
like i'm not your enemy
the guy was unwell he was off his meds
and he kept coming after him he tried to
take the gun from kyle kyle
was
kyle shadow and self-defense
the problem is that if you're at a
protest and you see somebody shoots one
of the protesters there you're gonna
perceive that as a [ __ ] threat so the
other guys that went running after him
were also acting in self-defense at that
point
because they think there's an active
shooter at a protest and what they're
doing is can be perceived as heroic and
brave to run towards someone who's a
gunman shooting protesters that's what
it looks like and there's no way to say
like nobody actually knows that
what happened there the problem is when
you put yourself in that situation it's
all goes to hell
kyle created that situation by being
there right so you know the thing is
they tried to get him on murder and
stuff and i didn't think i feel like you
could have got him on manslaughter or
something where he created 100
overcharged him yeah like insane
obviously i don't think kyle
it's a manslaughter he created this
[ __ ] horrible situation that he put
himself in that he needed didn't need to
be there that resulted in two people
dying and one person mammed you know
they overcharged him and he i don't
think like again he he was acting in
self-defense the issue is that he
created this situation and so he should
have been charged for manslaughter or
something like that which i do think
he's guilty of that's my [ __ ] take
fair enough i agree with most of that
what do you disagree with
well
i mean
no i i guess generally i do i i i
you honed in on it at the end there
which i think the big mistake is that uh
they tried to
get him on these charges when they
really should have just gone for the
lesser ones i don't know political
pressure probably is a big part of the
reason why they did try and go big well
you got it you've got to do a whole
breath
he was traveling in her state with a
weapon he was [ __ ]
you know creating
i don't know yeah why just charge him
for all these murder charges it doesn't
make sense obviously he's going to knock
he's going to get off on the murder
right because it's a people are saying
bad take why is it a bad take if you
think it's a bad take call in right
[ __ ] now and debate me
how about that let's not do that well
tell me why it's about taking chat then
because i'm just curious
what does chat know well i'm just
curious what's you know chad was saying
jordan peterson isn't religious earlier
you know what i mean oh yes he is
and this is what i'm saying
um that's my take bro
they overcharged him no way he was going
to get locked up
yeah i agree that overcharging was
psychotic the per the prosecutors were
absolutely [ __ ] horrible as
well um
why do you think it's a bad take i'm
genuinely curious i'm waiting for
comments
murderer
okay keemstar
so keemstar thinks kyle's a murderer
that's pretty based i feel like maybe
self-defense some people take that as
like a completely not guilty
way but i that's obviously not what
you're saying yeah i mean if you guys
listen to any point past that he
explained his reasoning i feel like
people jumped on that right away when
she said that
yeah and i mean the uh
like you said i think the really
pertinent thing is that it
if you narrowly examine it to just the
specific incidents
leading up to the shooting which is what
the trial ended up being because that's
you know they did not allow a lot of
extraneous circumstances or evidence to
become a part of the trial um that first
encounter with uh with rosenbaum who
is the
you know psycho dude who r worded
children and everything and he charged
him like yeah you know you could
perhaps make an argument that that was
in self-defense but uh like you said i
mean i think there's a pretty good
argument that it was in self-defense he
charged kyle yeah kyle said friendly
friendly friendly ran away from him he
only shot him once the guy got caught up
to him and tried to grab his gun and
brought him to the ground and
furthermore there was somebody a third
party uh who started firing his gun up
into the air who people don't know who
that was i don't think no they do yeah
they do no it was part of the trial that
guy's name is known he wasn't shooting
at any he shot his gun into the air
um
kind of coincidentally right at that
moment so from his perspective he
thought he was being shot at
um but like you said from that point on
the people he is in the middle of a
crowd just shot somebody and it's a
chaotic situation not everybody knows
what's going on and the other dudes were
just trying to stop what they thought
was an active shooter that's exactly
what i said he created a situation that
once you shot this guy even if he was
chasing you down
people are going to reasonably think
that you're just shooting protesters and
they have every [ __ ] right in fact
it's even heroic of them to step in in
interest of their self-defense and the
people around them self-defense right so
again he's responsible for the situation
being volatile and and out of control
there right you know
and yeah like you said he shouldn't have
been there in the first place uh i don't
see anybody trying
to argue against saying it's about he
didn't kill two black people he killed
one white person that's why he's saying
he supports bmw they love to contradict
themselves i don't even know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about but
if kyle only had a med kit strapped to
his chest instead of a rifle things
would have turned out differently of
course 100 because nobody else got hurt
there the only person the only time
someone got hurt people died
that he killed exactly exactly showing
up with a gun is anticipating
violence yeah well it's also vi it's
it's a vi it's an act of
to be even carrying it is an act of it's
like a it's a threat of violence should
be walking around with the [ __ ] ar
yeah
the people are saying are you missing
the fact that he's 17 no i'm not missing
the fact he's 17 what do you want me to
do
i mean
i do think it's weird that in our
justice system we have this rule that
you're 18 until you're an adult and then
but if people hate you enough or think
your crime is violent enough they'll
charge you as an adult i think it's
stupid if you're a kid you're a [ __ ]
kid if you're under 18 your brain don't
work so good and people have way better
chance of being rehabilitated although
not in our justice system which
basically
our justice system is like
anti-rehabilitation but you know what
yeah here's 17
so what i'm just talking about the
crimes
somebody disagree with me i [ __ ] dare
you
people just like to say bad take
bro i didn't someone said that didn't
mean you should get away with murder
okay
well
again
yeah i love y'all
but i'd love to hear what dan and
podcast because i oh so this guy wants a
dan ian podcast
he won't even talk how's he gonna do a
podcast i can't even get him to talk
i am switching
he's switching
someone said when you do any kind of
formal training they tell you never to
use your weapon to defuse a situation if
you're caring you have to clearly state
your intent to use deadly force that's a
that's exactly right
if you're walking around with a [ __ ]
rifle
you're telling you're signaling to
people around you that
you
are a threat you're a menace
he literally had a fire extinguisher in
his hand until somebody jumped him and
named a gun at him he did not instigate
nobody what else was
hold on hold on i gotta correct you
there because i'm very clear on this on
what happened because i've been trying
to formulate an opinion
so the first guy charged him
he shot him
it was at that point there was the guy
with the skateboard struck him with the
skateboard
he shot the guy with the skateboard the
third guy had a handgun in his hand
i don't think he ever pointed it to him
in fact
no he did he admitted to pointing it at
him and it's
he if you watch the video i i listened
to the trial he was saying he had the
handgun and he was running towards him
but he put his hands in the air
okay
and then kyle shot him in the [ __ ]
arm no i'm you want to get this right he
pointed the gun at him the guy himself
said it he yeah he's under oath in the
in the trial and you can see the video
that he points the gun at him
intentionally but he did okay there you
go
just because that was such a like
and he had previously in interviews
claimed that he didn't ever pointed the
gun at him but then when he was under
oath he had to admit that he did because
they showed a video of him doing it so
yeah i think he didn't want to get well
he heard gunshots he took his glock out
and started running towards the thing
whatever who cares it was an unsafe
situation for everyone
not good
it's just not good
don't go to protest with gun people
somebody [ __ ] disagree with me i'm
looking for anybody
um
it wasn't uh
please watch the video breakdown i'm not
doing that
um
this is too heavy for hdtv man let's
let's just move on here i'm at the end
of the show
are we ending it are we gonna end the
show
i mean the food's here how long we've
been oh the food's here what the [ __ ]
are we doing it's already five you
should watch jesus christ i think you
should watch the azalea banks clip
olivia one second
oh okay
power cleanser
it's just the audio from the tick tock i
sent you it's this long it seems like
most people agree with me but yeah he
literally had no intention of
participating in medical help he crossed
state lines and also mentioned
oh the chat moved it
yeah i mean look
i think he should have got manslaughter
that's my opinion
or reckless endangerment or exactly what
i mean like
and i do this is
drifting a little more conspiratorial
but you know they
sometimes they
they do overcharge people intentionally
that's all i'm going to say knowing that
it won't stick if they do that
interesting
yeah there was already a lot of people
the prosecutor was dog [ __ ] and also
kyle got like millions of dollars of
donation so he had like amazing uh uh
team
well-funded team and the litigation was
dog [ __ ] so there you go i mean
that's why he got off
if there was like if the person person
prosecuting him had as much funds as
kyle did then he probably would have
gone to jail for something else
you know
probably
dead air
we should watch that video and then
comments oh okay yeah i'm reading
comments all right so send it to me
it's in the chat okay this is
interesting
wendy williams
i think wendy williams orgasm looks like
when her eyes were popping out her head
before she passed out
yo
that [ __ ] probably unscrew her head and
soak it in a jar at night
what the [ __ ] no [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
good with wendy williams nose like you
ever seen like a cartoon drawing of a
frog and how like the frog don't really
got a nose he just got like holes on his
head
she's got like holes in her head like
you think when she comes she leaned her
head back
she was just all blown out from years of
heavy coke you was like
just raw
like you could see this you probably see
the [ __ ] brain when she looking ahead
back what's up what
i have a donation from ethan and ela
oh ela
says
this is bad take cake
hey what's my bad take you want it for
5.55
let's go
elo always got to come in and [ __ ]
heckle me during my own damn show that
was so funny she donated five dollars 55
cents she's keeping a fitty fist
straight with that bad take doing her
job from home
[Music]
damn you gotta heckle me [ __ ]
doesn't it usually have a check mark
the last time i think
i'm not sure um how can we see what
channel it
is just kidding hey ethan miss you she
donated another five dollars 55 cents i
can check in the back end yeah let's see
if it is i'm pretty sure it is real but
i mean uh i just
had the memory of it being verified last
time she donated but i might be wrong
let's see let's see if i'm getting
trolled by fake elo
a committed troll if it is i think it's
real though this is the that's the real
deal
that's the real lilo
please stand up so wait she left a nice
comment this time she said just kidding
hey ethan miss you oh thank you i love
you thank you so much
legend
bad take
so funny
what a comedian you are
all right let's continue this is pretty
epic actually this girl knows how to
throw down i don't even get insulted by
her
excuse me rocking the [ __ ] off
it's about eating 20 eggs
it's about steak it's about elk it's
about taking alpha brain
workout 10 hours a day
[ __ ] out bricks
eli just messaged our chat saying it's
really me yellow yeah it's me
i want to hear this again
william
bro you can't put the voice to text i
can't hear what she's saying just write
it i think i can the actual audio is
right here yeah i don't want to see this
guy
get off my feed man
i'm so sick of this
also can everyone's making fun of you
nobody actually likes that song dude
shut up [ __ ]
all right
fair enough
oh [ __ ] got him
good job send me the original timing on
that one you showed me the original [ __ ]
you rock
it looks like it was you shut up rock it
was like an instagram story right in the
middle of the night and so it's just a
black screen with a clock and then her
clowning
what the [ __ ] is this you set me down
some wild [ __ ] i was just sitting here
sitting here
what
what do you want just saying
just saying what
two hours ago
wendy williams is reportedly confined to
a wheelchair and is suffering early
signs of dementia dementia we didn't she
should show this
she's she's been having dementia for the
last 10 years oh no
oh no dance just like you believe me
from this conversation well dude it
would have been fine if you didn't
[ __ ] bring it up
like why the [ __ ] did you bring it up
because the chat was spamming it oh no
all right early signs of dementia what
does that mean i'm sorry i'm listening
to it oh we have a we have a counter
article hold on we might be okay to drag
her hold on not concerned william
brother shuts down rumors she's
suffering from dementia i mean yeah
she's weird you know what i mean it
doesn't mean she has dementia
just kidding
just saying
you know wendy williams would be dunking
on herself if she was doing her show
right all right get out of here with
this [ __ ]
even after death she'll still be going
yeah oh yeah
[Music]
wendy would want us to talk about her
bro this is the weirdest
worst audio
you know
and i don't know how i got on the topic
of wendy williams but
we were just like yo imagine what wendy
williams looks like when she has an
orgasm like that's probably the ugliest
thing you've ever [ __ ] seen
like oh my god i think wendy williams
orgasm looks like when her eyes were
popping out her head before she passed
out
yo
that [ __ ] probably unscrew her head and
soak it in a jar at night
no shade what the [ __ ] is good with
wendy williams nose like you ever seen
like a cartoon drawing of a frog and how
like the frog don't really got a nose he
just got like holes on his head that's
so good like she said i just got like
holes in her head like you think when
she comes she leaned her head back and
you can just see all her nostrils
she was just all blown out from years of
heavy coke you was like
just raw
like you could see the [ __ ] you
probably see the [ __ ] brain when she
leaning her head back
yo i swear to god that [ __ ] wendy
williams is a [ __ ] nematode
[ __ ] is a nematode that's interesting
hold on let's google nematode
character from spongebob
that is a that is a deep cut insult
interesting i think she just means that
she looks like a toad but a nematode
doesn't
doesn't actually look like a toad
yeah she's describing her nose which is
super accurate
nah but how you really look like the
toad
like a warty toad just sitting
inside a hole in a rotting log that's
what i've always thought about her that
you are a warty toad inside of a hole on
a rotting log
yo i just called the [ __ ] a toad
is that's that's so [ __ ] third gray
like [ __ ] you're not a fraud you're a
toad [ __ ]
ooh
what the hell
it's a great image
that's a getty in it damn how the [ __ ]
eyes really on the side of her head like
a toad too
[ __ ] was really a total in her past
life that's crazy
so now in hip-hop you could be like a
pretend gang member and a pretend rapper
and then it's just like the t
hip-hop y'all gotta do better your
[ __ ] gotta do [ __ ] better y'all are
really out of your [ __ ] mind i can't
believe nothing i'll make you say now
yeah that one's just a bonus
interesting those are for some pretty
good insults they're pretty mean
but uh
interesting
you know
wendy williams it's about power we stay
hungry we devour
all right that's it for us
damn we got through like nothing in this
hey i duck
you
someone said they've been on hold for
three hours yeah i'm sorry
um
oh i can fix that
did you just hang up on all of them yeah
yeah
you freed them try again uh next week
sorry
sorry all right well guys um we'll be
back on
well hold on actually we're we'll be
we'll be here on wednesday but that
episode will come out on thanksgiving so
have a good thanksgiving
members you'll get an episode on
wednesday the day before off the rails
also
shout out to the bts video that uh ab
uploaded was a hit if you guys want to
see gabe getting a lap dance uncensored
it's on the bts
and uh
it's available for members so all kinds
of good stuff back there for the members
thank you guys for your support
um
have a great thanksgiving so we'll see
you on thursday and on friday all right
god bless
be good
pick up for life be good for life for
real
i'm about to have a feet of my own
[Music]
so
[Music]
you